us
[Music]
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
assisting us today jennifer four
who is our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote
and we'll start the meeting by a calling
or by taking roll call attendance when
each member states their presence please
also state whether there's anyone in the
room with them
during the meeting which is required by
the right to know law
and mr clerk would you be willing to
call the role
i i
will so uh roll call i'll see
representative gordon
here and i'm at my at my home in bristol
and i
am by myself although my wife is could
be through the room to pass upstairs
representative mclean
here
representative sylvia
clerk
come on
representative alexander oh i'm alone
i'm in my house and my wife's doing what
she has to do
uh representative welper i'm here in
goffstown
what
okay
i am here at home and i have two kids
here and my dog
representative silber
uh i'm here at home in my home office in
guilford
and uh the only person here is
other than myself is my yorkie milly
representative green
i'm here
in my home in hudson with my wife
representative
i'm here in temple new hampshire alone
with my dog
representative tosh
representative trottier
good morning i'm here in belmont at my
residence
in my office i do have three children in
the house
representative smith
um good morning i'm here in durham alone
representative birch
uh good morning i'm here in west milan
alone
representative oregon
oh good morning i'm here in durham alone
i'm here at my home in newmarket and i'm
alone
where am i
lost my spot
okay representative kenny
i am here uh in my apartment in durham
i'm alone in my room but my roommates
are in the apartment
representative langley
good morning here in manchester and my
husband will be in and out
representative mcbees
good morning i'm alone in my office in
portsmouth but i have an adult uh
daughter that's in the house today
representative page
morning i'm in exeter in my home uh with
family but i'm in my home office
hello i'm here in exeter at my home uh
i'm alone my husband and two uh sons may
pass through at some point later in the
day just close the video
thank you
excellent
excuse me our first bill was we have a
aggressive agenda today
and uh i'm hoping that we'll be able to
get through it uh well
our first hearing this morning is on
house bill 227 it's relative to
termination of tenancy
at the expiration of the tenancy or
lease term
the prime sponsor is
former chief justice lynn now
representative lynn and
representative lynn are you available to
speak
i am can can you hear me
we can
great thank you very much mr chairman
uh the purpose of this bill
is uh to uh
ask the legislature
to overrule what i consider to be a very
unadvised decision of the supreme court
rendered
in 19 i'm sorry in 2005 in 2005
um at that time
the issue before the court was whether
the expiration
of the term of a lease
with respect to restricted property and
and by restricted property
that means property that is is
residential property that is leased
uh by by a landlord who
for lack of a better term is in the
business of leasing real estate uh it
wouldn't apply
for example to someone who
um
if you owned a uh
a duplex or a three or four family house
and you were you were an occupant yours
yourself
that would not be considered restricted
property if you leased less than
even if you don't live in in a
property if you if you
own less than i believe it is for
rental units you know
rental properties other other than the
property you live in then that's not
considered restricted property so it's
basically
the kind of property we're talking about
is
are
rental units that are rented by a
landlord who
for lack of a better term is in the
business of renting property that's uh
they they own they have you know a
substantial number of
properties
uh at any rate
the issue in this supreme court case
was
um
a landlord intended
entered into a lease for a term of one
year
and at the end of the term the landlord
notified the tenant that
he was not going to renew the lease
and the issue before the court was
whether under
rsa 540 colon 2
the termination of the leaf the end of
the least term constituted good cause
for
um
term for evicting the tenant um and the
supreme court in a four to one decision
held that it did not
that um the mere fact that the lease
term was up
um was not a good reason
to evict the tenant um
and the the
um
rationale for the case was
uh frankly
um
hard for me to understand it was based
on the idea that
um
the tenant um
the landlord in this circumstance is
really only interested in profit um has
no
uh interest beyond that and is law and
if there wasn't some
other reason uh
misconduct by the tenant or you know not
paying the rent or something like that
then the landlord shouldn't be able to
um
evict the tenant just because the lease
term had ended
justice nedo
um
concurred in the result only he he
concurred in the judgment because
on some other grounds but with respect
to that rationale
he essentially said look this
this ruling by the majority essentially
says that
if a landlord enters into a lease with a
tenant
the term of the lease doesn't really
matter the least potentially is a
perpetual lease
so that if you know unless the tenant
has done something else like failed to
pay the rent
or you know
interfered with other tenants or damaged
the property
the mere expiration of the lease term
is not enough
uh to evict the tenant so it i think
and i think justice nedo was absolutely
right in his in uh his disagreement with
the majority it it really says to a
landlord
um
when you enter into a lease the term of
the lease is in in many respects
meaningless it doesn't it uh because
you're
um you cannot
evict the tenant
even when the lease term expires
um
it seems to me that that
you know that is is really sort of a
fundamental at fundamentally at odds
with the notion of freedom of contract
um the landlord and tenant enter into an
agreement whether it's for a
you know
um a year lease or a five-year lease or
whatever the term of the lease may be
they both enter into that and there's no
suggestion there was no suggestion in
that case and there's nothing in uh
uh in the proposed legislation that
would say
that you know if there's if somehow a
landlord has misrepresented something to
a tenant about the term of the lease or
whatever that that that um that wouldn't
be a basis for granting the tenant some
relief but assuming both the landlord
and the tenant have
knowingly and understandably entered
into a lease for a specific term
this
the proposed legislation would say
that the expiration of the term of the
lease
is a grounds for evicting the tenant
um
the
the um the one caveat that you'll notice
in the legislation is
i did think that the majority in the and
the name of the case by the way i
just is aimco properties versus
dieselwitz
it's reported at 152 new hampshire 587
it was decided in 2005.
the one thing that that i thought that
the majority did have a point on and
that's the reason that i'll i'll get to
um why the legislation proposed
legislation is drafted as it is
is that
if you have a very short
for example a month to month lease term
unless there are other circumstances i
think that
there
you know there there probably is an
expectation
on the part
of both the landlord but particularly
the tenant that
if though if the lease is for a month is
on a month-to-month basis that assuming
the tenant
abides by the rules pays the rent
whatever the tenant is is not going to
be
you know told to leave at the end of the
first or second month uh you know some
very short period of time
so
to account for
for and i think in those circumstances i
think that an argument could be made
that it would that the landlord
shouldn't
be able to just end it at the end of the
first or second month or whatever and so
to account for that
this proposed legislation is drafted so
that it would
the the expiration of the term of the
lease
would only constitute a basis for
eviction
at the six-month point in other words if
the lease is for six months or longer
then the expiration of the lease would
be
a grounds for eviction or
to deal with the situation of a
month-to-month lease if it if there's if
there is in fact a month-to-month
tenancy
um
then
then the the x then at the end of of the
six month period of that in other words
when it when that tenancy has been
in effect for six months
then
the the next time it came up on the
seventh month for example would be
the basis for um
uh
or i'm sorry i guess i should say on the
uh when it came up for renewal at the
end
so that
it would be now in effect for six months
then that would be a the the landlord
would have the option to say
um i'm not renewing it
um i think that there are as i said i
think that
fundamentally the the majority's
decision in that case just really sort
of undercut
basic contract rights in my view and the
other thing i think as a policy matter
it i i actually think that
having the law the way it is may
actually inhibit
um landlords willingness
to uh rent to what
you know for example what i would
characterize as marginal candidates in
other words suppose that a landlord has
the opportunity to rent a property
to a tenant and the landlord is you know
you know
just based upon meeting with the tenant
talking with the tenant has some
question about
you know is is this is this tenant uh
going to be able to
uh
conduct uh himself or herself properly
are they gonna take care of the property
are they going to
not interfere with the neighbors are
they going to be you know sort of loud
a landlord might well conclude well look
i'm gonna rent to i'm gonna i've only
i'm only renting this property for six
months or a year
so
you know okay i'm running a risk uh that
maybe on maybe my
uh
decision to to rent the property is
wrong but it's only going to be for a
year but under under this supreme court
decision the landlord
has to has to basically think look
when i make when i make this uh this
contract
i'm i'm potentially
leasing this property in perpetuity to
the to the tenant because if the tenant
doesn't if the tenant doesn't you know
actually destroy the property and the
tenant pays the rent um
then i'm i'm i'm i'm on the hook i'm i'm
at risk for the entire
for however long the tenant might want
to stay there
so justice lynn i don't want to cut you
off but we we're only scheduled for a
half an hour this morning no i'm sorry
you're right so i'm i'm i'm done i think
i've basically stated the reason why i
think
uh this is important and i hope um i
hope the committee will agree
are there any questions from the
committee
yes representative alexander
um thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
is there ex was there um before the case
was ruled on was there um
like existing case law that would that
would indicate that they would rule that
way just based on past practices
now you know it's interesting i the um
the the
majority opinion does not
does not see suggest that
you know that there was prior case law
that that uh
that sort of supported his position they
they basically said that the statutory
language other good cause was ambiguous
and they went into legislative history
which said um
from which they drew the conclusion that
that you know
the end of the lease term was not um was
not
a was not good cause i
respectfully disagree with their
reasoning that's i guess that's all i
could say
seeing none thank you
representative glenn
thank you very much
i think
if if he's available let me see
he can only testify if he unmutes there
you go that took a little bit to find
can you hear me
we can okay awesome
let me clarify one thing when i signed
in i was going through the options there
was no option for advocate
the only option that seemed closest
appropriate was a lobbyist so i picked
that because there was no better choice
i'm not a lobbyist i'm an advocate for
property owners
i heard um that question
okay
so um many of you know me well short
introduction i lead
the
group of landlords across the state
involving new landlord tenant law
give a weekly update that goes out to
about four thousand different emails and
different associations around the state
so i'm involved with the landlords
across the entire state many
we're definitely in favor of this bill
i agree with the points that the sponsor
made and the problem that
exists here is that when a contract
expires we feel that the contract should
be up
one of the issues that is plaguing
property owners is that
it can be very hard to prove
situations
uh that would warrant evicting a tenant
or having them move if it's not
non-payment of rent
and there are many many issues where
you have a tenant maybe smoking in the
apartment that's against the rules
you have a tenant that's dealing drugs
using drugs
a tenant that's
a tenant that has unauthorized roommates
unauthorized pets being a disturbance to
the other tenants in the building
these things although theoretically you
could evict for
they're extremely hard to do and you
have to prove that in a court of law
and almost a hundred percent none of the
other tenants that are in the building
complaining about this bad behavior are
willing to testify in court because
they're afraid of retribution
so
the easiest thing
to do in this case would be to say at
the end of your lease we're not renewing
now that's not allowed
and it causes a lot of problems
and speaking to
some of our
landlord
specialist attorneys that specialize in
real estate
it's virtually impossible to get
somebody out that's dealing drugs you
can't prove it
so there are many instances that
for the protection of all the tenants
and the property and the building
we'd like to be able to
simply have a tenant move when it's the
end of the lease
i'm very willing to take question i i
would very much welcome questions i
often
observe that people don't quite
understand the real estate business
and i'm very familiar with it
i'm
ready for questions
go ahead
thank you are there any questions for mr
norman
i i see none mr norman at this point so
thank you for your testimony this
morning thank you very much
can you
can you hear me mr chairman we can hear
you elliot thank you
again um thank you my name is ellen
barry i'm the director of housing
justice at new hampshire legal
assistance i have been involved with the
statute since its initially good cause
eviction statute since its uh enactment
in 1985.
uh i actually had the chance to uh the
privilege to uh test to um argue the
jevitt's case before the new hampshire
supreme court
um i want to start by saying that
um
i have great respect
for former chief justice lynn and i
understand his position
uh under normal circumstances that
position would make perfect sense if
if you had a reasonable supply and
demand
situation but the problem is
that
only twice in my 40 plus years as an
attorney in new hampshire only twice has
there been a reasonable supply and
demand equation that one was during the
savings and loan uh
crash and then of course the 2007-2008
uh
real estate disaster and economic
disaster today we have a vacancy rate of
1.8
in belknap county it's one percent less
than one percent in rockingham county
the statewide median rent for a
two-bedroom apartment
1413.
that we have more than 30 000 households
in new hampshire who pay over half of
their income for rent
now
just by way of background
um uh
former chief justice lynn said correctly
that for very small-time landlords the
good cause requirement does not apply
but for all other landlords in new
hampshire it does and has been ever
since 1985
which means that if you in that a
landlord has to have a good reason to
evict somebody
now but and this is really
important
the it is not a perpetual lease the
landlord can evict not only for
something the tenant did wrong
but the tenant the landlord can evict
for other good cause and the statute
specifically says that other good cause
includes any legitimate business or
economic reason
if you need
to increase the rent and the tenant
chooses not to or can't afford to pay
the higher rent that is specifically
other good cause for eviction if the
landlord wants to renovate the property
that's other good cause for eviction if
he wants to sell the property in most
cases that will be other good cause for
eviction
the manufactured housing law the
eviction law which has existed since the
70s says in a mobile home park in a
manufactured housing park the only
evictions that are permitted are for
tenant fault and in that situation the
industry has been thriving not
withstanding a much tighter good cause
requirement
now
if a landlord who doesn't have a lease
has to prove good cause
why shouldn't a landlord a professional
landlord have to prove good cause in the
aimco case nco versus javits that the uh
justice referred to
that landlord was a mega corporation
owning
aimco properties operates all over the
country
and what they want to do
is just is have a what is essentially a
probationary tenancy in in hp 227 that's
a six-month probationary tenancy after
which time
you can just say no thank you i don't
want you here anymore
if the court's decision in javits and
i'm just to read briefly from it but i
think i think they got it just right
it says we're the mere expiration of the
leaps that constitute good cause for
eviction it could enable landlords to
evict when the true reason for eviction
it was enacted to prevent landlords from
evicting tenants for ill motivated
reason
if if the mere expiration of the lease
were good cause a landlord who did not
wish to continue to renting to a tenant
for any reason
for example because the landlord the
tenant became disabled during the course
of the tenancy he could evict the tenant
at the end of the lease
let me just ask you this i assume that
most of you are homeowners
so what would you think
if the bank
that holds your mortgage
every six months could come along and
say you know what i'll give you back
your money but i want you to move
the forceful eviction
can lead you it
obvious to the fact that kids have to go
to a different school people have to go
to a different city or town that they
can lose mental health providers they
can lose their you know their doctor
they lose their community and all too
often in the market we have it leads to
absolute homelessness
i urge you i know there's so many things
i could
talk to about here but just
but i i won't let me just say two things
number one our neighbors in vermont
um i'm sorry oh
let me just go that there was a letter
written um to the committee by paul
stewart of stuart property management
they managed 3 000
3 000 units across new hampshire and the
question is they are opposed to this
because they understand the dangers
involved in uh and the the lack of
rationality
for allowing people to be evicted from
one of life's most basic necessities to
lose that without establishing good
cause doesn't make sense in a market
like this and i'll say one final thing
one of the things that does happen more
often than not in my experience is when
you have a lease expiration and a
subsequent eviction the result most of
the time is a negotiated settlement in
which the tenant gets the time to
maximize their chance to find another
place
um that's the practical on the ground so
okay
if you could just wrap up i am very
i'm i'm done and i'd be happy to answer
any questions representative sylvia do
you have a question
yes just briefly
if um
we acknowledge that there is a
supply problem in rental
can you understand how the state
interference with these contracts is
causing such problems to vary
i can't except for one thing
representative sylvia i there are
countless developers out there who are
dying to create multi-family housing and
are creating an enormous demand for
rental housing uh that they complain uh
is being uh thwarted by municipal uh
regulations i don't see any lack of
interest in becoming a landlord
thank you
okay
thank you very much see
uh thank you for your testimony today
the next person to testify would be tara
reardon
i'm sorry can you hear me now
we can thank you i appreciate it mr
chairman um good morning mr chairman
members of the judiciary committee my
name is tara reardon i am the director
of the resident owned communities at the
new hampshire community loan fund and by
way of background
i practiced law in the real estate area
for 20 years and have served seven terms
in the legislature
on the commerce committee i'm currently
in my position as the director of
resident owned communities those are
resident owned manufactured housing
parks that are run by the residents that
live there
we work with 134 communities that
represent over 8
200 households and
rsa 540 is not the only eviction statute
i think elliot berry just referred to
this the manufactured housing eviction
statute is contained in 205 a
and it also covers almost mirroring the
same provisions cause causes for
eviction non-payment of rent failure to
comply with local regulations disturbing
the peace of other
uh residents and the failure to comply
with rules our only difference is also a
park closure is the only exception to
the cause um
for the eviction and we have um done
evictions for all of the things that
have been named in this test of
testimony violation of rules repeatedly
drug dealing in the community during my
tenure at the resident on community
within those confines and we don't have
the other good cause or business or
economic uh reason um piece that is in
540. so our manufactured housing statute
is a little more restrictive when it
comes to evictions it has been there for
50 years though and i would say it has
worked every time we have needed needed
it when somebody has to be
evicted i want to just reiterate what
elliot just said in a time when rental
vacancies are almost non-existent the
housing supply for purchase is less than
a month if we no new homes came on the
market the supply would be completely
exhausted in three weeks in the state of
new hampshire that housing is really
critical for all kinds of lifetime
reasons as elliott was just saying
when and i think public policy warrants
making housing more secure
not less secure at this point
more stable particularly when because of
our new hampshire constitution that
burden is going to fall on your cities
and towns if in fact people are homeless
because they can't find housing that's
what our per um
our
constitution provides so i i would i
would go back to um justice lynn's
marginal candidate that he talked about
and all of those examples that he gave
about you know conducting themselves
probably properly uh damage noise all of
those those are already contained as
cause in the statute and in my practice
and in what i'm seeing in manufactured
housing those are working just fine so i
would caution i i'm opposed to the
passage of house bill 227 and i would i
would caution the community to think of
not from a contractual standby but the
broader public policy reasons to not
implement this at that time
thank you mr chairman and i'd be glad to
take any questions if there are any
are there any questions for
singh none
thank you for your testimony today
uh next person to testify we have two
more people to testify one of whom is
i am here can you hear me weekend
terrific uh thank you chairman gordon
and members of the judiciary committee
for giving me the opportunity to speak
today
um my name is keith tebow
um i represent southwestern community
services we're a community action agency
and
serving cheshire sullivan counties
formed in 1965 we provide a
myriad of human and social service
programs
uh throughout southwestern new hampshire
and in addition
we have developed we own and operate
nearly 500 apartment units in
southwestern new hampshire between
cheshire and sullivan counties and i
we oppose this bill
um
any bill that potentially reverses a
supreme court ruling really does need or
i think bears a need for heightened
level of scrutiny uh and for good reason
um
as we know this bill would allow most
landlords to utilize leases to evict a
tenant upon the termination date of a
lease with no cause beyond the fact that
that there's a date in that lease
um we find this problematic on two
primary counts
first um this would give unilateral
control of an eviction to any landlord
who utilizes a lease
in effective this gives a landlord
powers that were formerly only allocated
to a judge the power to evict is
in our opinion not to be taken lightly
the power to put an individual a family
a child out of their home
um
needs to be wielded by an objective
third party who can weigh the reasons
and justifications for such a powerful
decision
um
the second consideration that it feels
we need to be considered is what at
least means to both the landlord and a
tenant
there are
there are benefits and responsibilities
within the lease for both parties
um it's meant to protect a landlord
against a tenant who
negatively affects the
um the development they live in it also
allows the family
to
within a certain set of behaviors allows
for the resident the lease is a security
instrument
it ensures that if certain behaviors are
responsibilities are fulfilled they
remain in control of an asset
because truly a lease
for for a person who's renting is an
asset whether they realize it or not and
it's an important asset
a safe and secure home
with a right to live there secured by a
lease
the lease which
outlines acceptable behavior and
reasonable expectations is a powerful
and a real asset to a family
allowing the landlord to strip a family
of this asset for really no good cause
is not acceptable a good lease works
both ways it's not just there to protect
the landlord from a resident it's vice
versa
we have had to evict people for
drug possession
for unauthorized people living there for
smoking we have managed to to
secure an eviction on every one of those
causes
um there are lease violations and if you
do your job as a landlord you will you
will be able to
evict a resident if indeed they've
broken their rules
so should an eviction action become
necessary it absolutely needs to be
adjudicated by a judge not unilaterally
by one party or the other and this is
only exacerbated
as other speakers have mentioned today
given our current housing situation in
new hampshire
the ability to find a home is incredibly
difficult in order and
and once you secure that home
and you follow the rules by which you've
agreed to and the landlord has agreed to
again this leases is when it's put into
place it's it's in it is
to benefit both parties so as an
advocate um
for people who rent housing and as a
local landlord southwestern opposes
house bill 227 i certainly can take any
questions and i really appreciate your
time today
thank you very much are there
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
and the last person who's signed up to
i don't see him in the attendee list if
you could raise his hand maybe we could
i do not see him and
so we
there
is a
uh and
i would note that
people who had science uh who had
entered
uh their position prior to the hearing
there were 26 people who indicated that
they did not wish to speak
but they were in support of the bill and
there were seven people who indicated
they didn't wish to speak but were in
opposition to the bill
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
today
hello
my name is martin toe
yes um i think do you wish that you wish
to speak today
yes i do
okay
um i i
i wanna thank uh
every rep
and um everyone who's working on on this
and
on this hearing
um my name is marunto i'm a hooksett
resident
um
i wanted to share my testimony and first
of all i want to say that i
i'm in support of this bill
um
i used to live in concord i moved to
manchester
um two years ago with my mother um in
hopes of a new start uh while in
manchester uh we faced multiple
difficulties
um
one of them being that in the house that
we were living in or renting
um during the winter time uh
the the uh the the heat the heat went
off
um
and
we weren't able to
you know
the we we spoke to the landlord about
the situation and
asked if he could you know fix it um
since it was winter and the landlord um
you know didn't do that and so we had to
seek help outside of
communicating with our landlord
and so we actually got code involved and
code um came and
checked out the place and
um
and said yeah the heat's not working the
pipe that brings the heat to your unit
is broken
and
you know
having that knowledge that our landlord
still didn't
still didn't fix the place up um didn't
fix the heat
which was crucial during the winter
um
i'm bringing this up because
you know
i would say i'm a reasonable person and
as a christian and
a believer
i think that fairness is something that
we should all strive for in a uh
as a communi uh as a in our community
here in new hampshire
um
that means fairness for renters and
landlords um i believe that right now
you know
with the soul of america
at stake in
people um
struggling to make ends meet
especially for uh renters
um communication is super important um
uh in a situation where you know a
renter
may not you know have necessarily have
no control over what you know a
circumstance maybe they lost their job
or maybe their employer cut their um
hours that they're working
i think it's it's always it's um by
it's it's important for to seek fairness
in that situation
and give people a fair chance um
if the landlord wants i'm i'm gonna wrap
up
um if the landlord wants uh
you know
the tenant to
get out or leave
i think the
tenants should at least have a ch um
a fair chance of finding a another place
where in our situation we you know we we
left
not because we weren't able to pay our
rent
um we had to leave because it was unsafe
for us um
no heat
you know um
is you know heat is a central thing so i
think if you can give people fairness
um to stay housed and not be thrown in
the streets
and um with right now with our
overwhelming uh population of
homelessness um it would it would do us
good to not add on to that
thank you so much
thank you for your testimony are there
see none thank you for your testimony
today mr true thank you
okay
i see representative lynn has his hand
up representative lin do you
have something to add today
[Music]
you know i i there's just one point i i
realized i really wanted to do it very
briefly because we're way over time i i
will and i realize i thank you for
permitting me i realize that you've got
a very busy day there was only one point
that was mentioned
by one of the witnesses that i think
it's important to
to address
particularly for those members of the
committee who are not lawyers the
suggestion was made that because this
legislation would overrule
a supreme court decision that somehow
sort of some special there needs to be
some special reason to do that um i i
think the lawyers in the room will will
understand that that is absolutely not
the case if
if if if this were and a case before the
supreme court or
of new hampshire and the question was
should that decision uh the the aimco
decision be overruled yes it's very true
that the the doctrine of starry decisis
would require that that there be some
special reason not just that the case
was was wrongly decided but some special
reason to overrule it but that
absolutely does not apply
to you as a legislator you are the
representative of the people
there's no special rule that applies you
just have to decide what is the right
decision to make and that's really all i
have that's all i have to say thank you
very much and i'm sorry uh i know you're
you're
thank you for your testimony
and with that i'm going to close the
hearing on representative smith had a
question mr i'm sorry
representative smith a very uh quick
question um
for represented
representative lynn on i'm sorry
mr chairman i know your time is sure
but does um representative lin believe
that
in
the new hampshire house of
representatives it is only lawyers who
can understand
the implications of the relationship
between law
and actions of the judicial branch
no i don't but i do think that it's that
lawyers are are apt to be
more familiar with the doctrine of
starry decisis than
than non-lawyers i i'm i'm i
you know i've uh as a non-lawyer if uh
if if you you may you may very well be
aware of that but i suspect that there
may be many not many non-lawyers who are
not
thank you for your question thank you
for your response representative lynn
and with that i will close the hearing
on house bill 227 and
i'm going to give the clerk a couple of
which he has asked me to do what's next
mr chairman
i note on house bill 160 that there are
eight people who have signed up to speak
so and we are behind we are behind right
now and so i am going to ask my
people if they would
keep their
testimony concise and to the point
the prime sponsor of that bill is
representative conley
and i don't see representative conley
having signed up
and but i see that representative conley
is on the attendee list so i will
i will call upon representative conley
to introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman committee members
just want to make sure you guys can hear
me loud and clear
we can okay
um so yes casey conley state
representative from dover here to
introduce hb 160.
this bill would require advance notice
for rent increases that exceed five
percent
as many on this committee know and have
already heard this morning uh
we have a real housing crisis in the
state
um
and as we heard uh the median cost of a
two bedroom apartment now exceeds 1400 a
month that uh increased by five percent
over 2019 despite the covet 19 pandemic
um the vacancy rates uh have remained
quite low
um
despite the pandemic
you know over the last five years
uh rents in stratford county where i
live have grown by 26 percent
uh same in hillsborough it's even higher
in rockingham 28
double-digit increases in sullivan
grafton coast counties
um
so we know that there's a real
affordability challenge in the state
um
and this is just this is not sort of an
abstract data set you know we know we
heard earlier this year the governor's
office
uh for emergency relief and recovery go
for heard testimony just highlighting
the hardships faced by our state's
tenants
we heard from a prominent economist that
half of renters in the state are paying
more than 30 percent of their income for
rent
so in this era of steadily rising rents
uh very low vacancy
this bill is one key objective it's just
to give renters sufficient time to find
replacement housing in the event that
their existing rental
is set to increase beyond what they can
afford when their lease ends
so we know the current law gives 30 days
or requires 30 days notice for these
higher rents many landlords in the state
voluntarily give additional time they
let their tenants know
with much more notice but not all of
them
so 30 days you know in this low vacancy
market
where it's hard to find uh replacement
housing just isn't enough time
uh it used to be as many of us can
recall you know you if you're priced out
of one unit or you're you want to move
for some reason you can just look around
the corner look elsewhere in your
community but that's not the case
anymore it's not hard to imagine you
know someone forced to move due to you
know rising rent
having to change jobs
take their kids out of school find new
child care
all these things
and it's a direct link between the high
cost of housing in new hampshire and the
worsening homelessness crisis that we're
seeing playing out in our cities
and communities
around the state including on the
seacoast
members of this committee might remember
an earlier version
of this bill
last year passed
the committee and the house with
bipartisan support it died in the senate
in the covid shortened session
it's worth making very clear that this
bill would not in any way restrict how
much any landlord could charge any
tenant for rent at any time
this is strictly about requiring notice
for higher rents and only rents that
exceed a certain threshold
so i asked this committee to recommend
passage to small but important
protection
for you know new hampshire renters so
that i'm happy to take any questions
thank you representative are there any
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
i'm sorry
thank you mr chair
yes i do yeah
um thank you representative connolly for
taking my question um i'm looking at
lines um 21 to 25 on page
one
um page one it says like if a landlord
increases more than one notice or issues
more than one dose of rent increase in a
six day period um basically says that
like
um it
after the it's after the last six it's
60 days after the last notice of rent
increase
um i guess my question is could a
landlord issue a notice of rent increase
for five days like every day for five
days of like five percent and that still
works under this
bill
thank you representative uh the intent
of that is to
prevent um
a landlord from using smaller increment
increases over over an extended period
to sort of bypass the limits outlined in
the bill
um
i i don't believe the scenario you
describe would be possible under the
under the the terms of this bill that's
are you all set representative alexander
are there any other questions for
representative connolly
sing none thank you again thank you for
your testimony
the next person to testify will be nick
norman
there we go i found it quickly this time
uh thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity to speak okay thank you very
much
and um so same introduction before
um so
we would be against this bill i'm
talking about property owners and
landlords
anytime that you are controlling
rents
then you're starting rent control
this is the beginnings
beginnings of rent control rent control
is a failed policy proven over and over
again across the entire country
it leads to
warped rental markets in terms of
amounts of rent
uh un
uh maintained properties just many many
problems so
this is although you may think it's
small it's the camel's nose and the tent
of rent control and definitely should be
there are many situations where
landlords are faced with enormous
increases in expenses
it might be new heating systems new
major systems roofs we've had some
landlords that have had 20 increases on
property taxes
uh how landlords recoup those expenses
really ought to be up to
the landlord
there's a fundamental flaw with the way
that the bill is designed
and
what happens in our rental market now is
that tenants are required to give a
30-day notice whenever they want to
leave
so if tenants are giving 30-day notices
but the landlord is giving 60-day notice
of rent increase and someone says okay i
want to take this extra time to look for
something on the market
they're going to find a very limited
supply on the market that's 60 days out
an extremely limited supply on the
market is 90 days out what that's going
to do
is create waiting lists and extra demand
for apartments
and
falsely yet again increase the demand
for
rental housing without increasing the
supply and that's going to drive up
rents so there's an extremely
fundamental flaw with the way that the
bill is written is going to actually
cause a worsening of the
housing
affordable housing issue
[Music]
and this goal can be entirely
accomplished by existing contract law
tenants and landlords can make
agreements about rent increases
tenants can can ask three months before
the end of the lease about what the the
new rent is going to be all of this can
be worked out by mutual agreement
there's no need for a law
we would please recommend that this be
killed
and voted inexpedient to legislate
i am very much available for questions
and would very welcome questions thank
you very much
hey oh yes representative maclean
yeah um just a quick question um given
given the the limitations in the housing
market right now
um
if the bill were amended to say that
that 60-day relationship had to be both
sides you know not just from the
landlord but also from the tenant would
that equilibrate things um or would you
see that as problematic as well
well it would make it more equal
it would be better i i think it's still
problematic to be legislating things
like this
we have an essential problem with
affordable housing that's definitely a
problem i agree that's a problem but
that problem is created by
legislation
anytime there's an additional regulation
an additional restriction ultimately
that furthers
the
pushing up rents rental supply down and
continues to worsen the housing
affordability problem
so yeah it'd be a little bit better but
there
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much mr norman you mentioned the
replacing the heating system and your
email you mentioned uh
other capital expenses um
why is it unreasonably expect landlords
to do what other businesses do and you
know maintain a capital budget you know
set money aside
for possible capital expenses especially
if you're a large landlord even though
you don't know when the eating system
one building might fail it's fairly
predictable over time so why not
expect landlords to deal with capital
expenses the way
all other businesses do rather than just
allowing them to you know
raise the price
raise the price with with no notice um
when their customers uh can't easily
move to another apartment so
um
and i understand the part of the the tax
increases um even though tax rates don't
go up pretty particularly sometimes the
assessments go up so why
why can't landlords do capital managers
handle them the same way every other
business does
thank you
thank you for the question
representative
so it's just not always possible we do
the best that we can you'd be surprised
the margins on real estate are much
smaller than you realize
and
it's
it's it's not that simple is your answer
if we can yeah we're building a capital
reserve
and that could be replaced over time
but it's just many times not possible
the amount of rent versus the amount of
expenses and the increased regulation
that costs more and more money is making
thank you a follow-up mr chair if you
yeah although i don't know
um what is
and
guess like
not an attorney so i'm asking a question
i don't really know the answer to but
what how does this work in the
commercial real estate market where the
power differential between the tenants
and the
landlord is uh you know much less said
um so how does this how does how is this
issue resolved in um in commercial
leases
which are very different from
residential leases i understand
right uh thank you for again for the
question i'm going to have to say that i
am not an expert in commercial real
estate well meaning
all of my
real estate is residential
and um
i would say probably 95 or more of the
contacts in my large network that i deal
with with landlords are all residential
apartments so i could not give you a
good answer to that question all right
oh thanks that's fine
thank you mr chairman so my quick
question is does this bill even pertain
to commercial real estate
um i thought
it was for just for residential
and i'm new at this so bear with me
uh line four it says this section shall
apply to all residential rental property
so this doesn't even apply to commercial
is that correct that's the way i would
understand it exactly line four says
specifically residential property except
non-restricted and non-restricted is
residential
a small
subclass of residential
thank you
any other questions for mr
norman i see none thank you mr norman
for your testimony
and next person to testify is a martha
stone
yes
hello can you hear me we can okay sorry
zoom froze right at the right moment
uh sorry about that good morning i'm
marcus stone i'm the executive director
of crossroads house one of the state's
largest
emergency shelters and i'm also a
landlord in that we own
um some residential rental units for
people who have experienced homelessness
and are ready to move out to permanent
housing
um thank you for allowing me the time i
know you're running behind so i'll be
i'll be concise um i just wanted to um
speak in support of house bill 160 this
morning and let you know that large
increases to rent
can and has caused
in the past people to become homeless
i testified
regarding this bill last year when you
were hearing it and shared a story which
i will just very briefly summarize for
you today
we had a 70 year old resident come to us
um
who was living on his social security
payments he was living in an apartment
that uh he was paying 770 for rent uh
there was a change in management the
rent went up to 1 595
and um
he gave his notice to property manager
but there was a change in staffing and a
miscommunication and so his
um notice
was not received by the new company and
therefore on their records he owed this
even though he tried to leave because he
couldn't afford it
he was being held accountable for this
new rent of almost 1600 a month which
then prevented him from
um applying for and getting a new
apartment so it's a little bit of a
complicated situation but the bottom
line is large rental increases
where people do not have enough time to
[Applause]
find a new place to live can cause
people to become homeless
as one of the largest shelters in the
state i can tell you
that
we serve people who have experienced a
lot of different
challenges i won't reiterate what's
already been spoken about the state of
the
um housing market but i will say that
the lack of affordable housing
is one of the greatest challenges that
we face in helping people exit our
shelter
our lengths of stay how long people stay
in our shelter has been steadily
increasing over the past five years and
i really believe a part of that is the
fact that there's just so few places for
people to go so once people are are
housed
i think it's critically important that
we do everything we can to keep them
stably housed
and having opportunities and time to
move should a rent increase happen
um is just one factor i think that would
would help so
again i appreciate your time this
morning and i'd be happy to answer any
questions that you may have
thank you for your testimony
great thank you
thank you again mr chairman i i speak in
support of uh hb 160. just um i'll be as
brief as i can
number one
it's important to note the number of
exceptions in the coverage of the bill
so that small landlords are not affected
but more fundamentally if you are a rep
if you're renting the a fourteen hundred
and thirteen dollar a month two bedroom
apartment the statewide median
you can increase your rent 70
a month
and not be affected by this bill
say you're lucky you're you know you
found a place for a thousand dollars a
month
because a five percent increase which is
a threshold where the bill kicks in you
can still have to eat a 50
a 50 a month rent increase
uh and the bill has no effect whatsoever
to call this rent control
i'm sorry but that's absolute nonsense
but vermont by the way requires a 60 to
a 60-day notice for all rent increases
maine 45-day notice for all rent
increases the landlord can rent the
raise the rent as much as he or she
wants and the only effect is that of
this bill is that you may have to give
up to 60 days at two months notice
i don't think that's asking very much
and if they're worried about a rent
control bill i'm sure they'll be back
big time
uh to oppose the rent control bill and
quite frankly i can't imagine that you
all would pass it
um
i think one other thing in when you get
into the issue of repairs
right you may have to make some capital
improvements guess what you don't just
go into your bank account and take the
money to do that you go to the bank and
you figure out some financing for the
repairs and as uh
paul stewart pointed out in his letter
in support of
160 the very large landlord
you're gonna you're gonna arrange your
financing
in a period that will take 60 days
there's no problem in building in a
60-day period
while you're negotiating your financing
for the you know for the rehabilitation
this is just a simple bill to give
people the maximum opportunity possible
to find a
replacement housing uh in a very very
tight market
um so i urge you to pass the bill i
promised i would be briefed and this is
briefer than i ever am thank you and
it's much appreciated so is there any
questions for mr barry
attorney barry
[Music]
dignan thank you for your testimony
today thank you very much next person to
hello can everyone hear me
we can
thank you
my name is chris norwood and i'm the
public policy chair for 2021 for the new
hampshire association of realtors i
represent some 7 000 members
and we are opposed to house bill 160 as
drafted
i do want to reference representative
horrigan's question about commercial
tenancies and while this is a
residential bill
i think that representative horgan's
question does reference what we feel is
the remedies provided to landlords and
tenants right now are to sign a
longer-term lease
that protects both landlords and tenants
by fixing their costs and their income
stream and that's what currently takes
place in the commercial market and it's
by and large what i predominantly
practice uh in our business
we recognize that there's vacancy
challenges
and cost of rental we do feel that the
solution
is increase in inventory
not to
provide measures such as house bill 160.
increasing cost liability and
regulations we feel will lead to
consolidation whereby the mom and pop
property owners will leave and
consolidation will take place while with
larger landlords acquiring more property
thereby limiting competition
we do not think that that helps tenants
uh other folks have talked about uh
property owners not being able to
accurately predict their expenses um
there's there's other expenses in here
that change sometimes utility costs are
included within rent so not just the
capital
costs of putting in a new boiler let's
say but the actual fuel costs are
included in the rent
um so in the end i'll just try and be
brief we feel that the uh the bigger
answer to the rent problem is simple we
think we need more apartments we need to
make housing more available uh we do not
think that this is the solution we think
that this um will create more
consolidation and we do think that there
are remedies presently available which
again are
locking in longer term leases for both
parties
so we would appreciate you to itl
hb 160.
thank you mr chair
thank you for your testimony any
seeing them thank you
thank you
um
i will be brief i will not go through my
uh introduction again
thank you
you're welcome except to remind folks
that we do own operate manage and
maintain over 500 units of housing in
southwestern new hampshire as a landlord
we are in support of this bill
um
a 60 to 90 day notice for five and eight
percent rent increases is reasonable
certainly fair in this housing market uh
speaking as both a landlord as well as
an advocate uh the effect of such an
increase is exponentially larger for any
individual family that lives paycheck to
paycheck
um
proper notice is a term widely used and
respected in this industry in rental
housing industry
given our housing market this sort of
minimal tenant protection we're not
saying they can't do a five or an eight
percent increases they have to wait an
extra 30 or 60 days to allow the family
or the household to either either find
another place which is a
a high bar or rearrange financing so
they can they can they can deal with the
with the rent increase
proper notice
from large increases in housing costs
appear prudent
equitable proper so we are in support of
160 thank you very much
any questions for mr tebow
again thank you for your testimony today
we have three more people who have
signed up to speak all uh indicating
that they're in support of the
legislation
and hopefully they can be brief the
yes thank you so much for having me my
name is harrison kansler i'm the
executive director of the mount
washington valley housing coalition
we are in support of this bill
i several of my points have already been
brought up so i will go straight to the
economic situation in the mount
washington valley right now a part of
the reason we support this bill is that
far too often our employers who are
already closing their shops and their
locations
more often than is typical are having to
shut their doors even more frequently
because they are losing their employees
rent increases are definitely something
that we are familiar with here in the
valley as more folks are buying up
property here and raising rents
but the problem is in in carroll county
we actually have about a zero percent uh
vacancy rate so
even if you had 90 days it would be very
hard we see the 90 days more uh the 60
or 90 days more as an opportunity to
readjust your budget potentially
approach your employer and figure out
how you can afford that increase um
which would go a huge way for our
employers to be able to keep their doors
open
um you know if
if an employee should lose their housing
it is likely that they will have to
leave the area uh because they just will
not have any other opportunity to find
housing in the area
so for that reason we support the bill i
did send a more in-depth written
testimony and i would ask that you
please read that thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions
for mr kansler
seeing them again thank you
hi everyone um erica perez is actually
going to speak on behalf of new
hampshire youth movement here she should
be up next but i'm just here in full
support of this bill i really believe
that people deserve notice before
rent increases in case they need to find
another place to live i live in dover i
know the housing market here is
extremely expensive and i know a lot of
people have had to move out of the area
because of rent increases young people
in particular um are
often renting and you know struggling to
afford places especially here in the
covid pandemic so i just ask you to
be kind to renters and give them
more of a heads up notice but i'd love
hey erica prez perez did not sign up to
speak until i see she's an attendee
hi um thank you for allowing me to speak
um
my name is erica perez i'm with the
hampshire youth movement and i'm from
manchester new hampshire
um
so it may seem reasonable to raise rent
if a landlord sees fit but to allow the
whims of someone who makes their living
from someone else's need for a home
isn't reasonable
notice is the very least that new
hampshire renters deserve even 60 days
is not enough notice but it's something
that we could settle for new hampshire
has a minimum wage of 7.25 which i'm
sure you're all aware but we do have
high rents lower rent areas may not be
the safest or the best place to live and
landlords take advantage of the fact
that there is no better place to go
economically
um representative horgan made a great
point earlier if renters are indeed a
business they should take responsibility
for their properties in the upkeep so
that they don't need multiple occupants
to fork over more money that they may
not have especially in a pandemic where
many people have had their hours cut and
seen their savings dwindle
once you have strike against your
renters history it is incredibly hard to
find housing because people refuse to
run to you despite your circumstances no
matter the circumstance um and landlords
already have protections in their
contracts that they write up um renters
deserve protections too and with all due
respect to someone who has lived off of
eight dollars an hour with a rent um of
400 at the time even a 20 increase in my
rent would have crushed me seeing as i
was already struggling to pay for things
like gas and rent and new clothing um so
frankly any opposition to this bill is
frankly a sign of greed um and thank you
for listening and for your time
sing none thank you for your testimony
ms barrett
and the last person who signed up to
i
is um
and is there anyone else i see you
there's one hand up
alissa margolin
[Music]
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify in support of house bill 160
my name is alyssa margal and i serve as
director of housing action new hampshire
we're a statewide coalition of 80
organizations united around affordable
housing policy our members are
affordable housing developers
folks who
manage
affordable housing properties those who
finance affordable housing properties
also
family and children's advocates and
supportive housing and homeless service
providers we're very pleased to support
this proposal
we view this bill as a notice bill uh
essential to creating housing stability
the issue of housing stabilities move
front and center during the pandemic you
know how do you comply with a
stay-at-home order if you don't have a
home how are you safer at home if you
don't have a place to live
we need notice because of our supply
program the latest data are that new
hampshire needs 20 000 more
units to meet demand
we are very appreciative of mr norwood's
association's attention to the supply
problem but it will take some time and
uh notice is just a good policy
has been noted the bill doesn't limit in
any way what a landlord can charge it
can certainly pass along
increases
to capital expenses fuel
what it does
simply acknowledge is that if you go
forward with an increase and that's more
than your current tenant can afford that
you just give them enough time to find a
new place i really don't think there's
any economist that would say that giving
more notice drives up costs
is housing a right or a widget purchased
on the market i noted uh this when i
testified in support of this bill last
year i imagine that every of you member
of your committee may feel a little bit
differently about this and no matter
where you fall along that continuum we
can all agree that if you don't make
enough to afford a major increase in
your rent but it's just good public
policy to give you enough time to find
another one so we urge your ought to
pass recommendation for house bill 160
thank you
thank you any questions from his
margalin
sing none thank you for your testimony
that's all i have for speakers uh
currently
and
i see a hand up for martha stone but she
so with that i'll close the hearing on
house bill 160.
i'd note that there were
numbers of people who signed up either
in support or opposition there were 36
people who signed up in support of the
bill
and 18 who signed up in opposition to
the bill indicated they did not wish to
speak
after we hear house bill 550
550 house bill 550 is relative to the
non-payment of rent during the state of
emergency
again the
primary sponsor of that bill is
representative conley
and i see representative conley is
on our list of attendees and
representative conley would you like to
introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman committee members
again casey conley state representative
from dover uh and
hb 550 does one critically important
thing
it would halt the eviction process for
non-payment of rent for no more than 30
days if and only if the tenant can show
they've applied for assistance through
one of the housing
assistance programs now available in our
state
that period is intended to give the
tenant and the landlord potentially time
to pursue that funding
that we know
will be available now under the
stimulus program approved by congress or
the relief program excuse me
these provisions would be temporary they
would expire
when the covid19 state of emergency ends
as we know the pandemic has caused a lot
of uncertainty a lot of job loss a lot
of reduced hours
a number of federal programs have
emerged to
extend or expand our safety net
um
but despite these programs we know from
the time in which the eviction
uh
ban expired this summer to the end of
the year we know there were hundreds of
evictions so the circumstances for each
aren't obviously available but it's safe
to presume that a number of those people
who lost their homes to do non-payment
would have qualified for assistance
and it's also safe to presume that many
people did not know these programs
existed they had
difficulty accessing them
or any number of other challenges might
have arisen
so again this 30-day period just gives
people facing eviction this narrow
window to pursue this support before
they lose their home
it does not
in any way sort of allow them to not pay
rent or or otherwise violate the lease
so in short it's just a temporary and
critical lifeline for tenants facing
financial difficulties due to the
pandemic
the governor to his credit uh really
worked hard to try to address this issue
last year
[Music]
and i would consider this bill to be
something that meshes with uh what the
governor and gopher has already acted on
so thank you for your help uh for your
uh time and appreciate
uh
your your time and i'm happy to take
questions representative conley did you
submit written testimony
uh representative i did not i'm happy to
is are there any other questions for
seeing none thank you thank you for your
testimony i have a question if that's
okay yes yep you sure
um thank you representative for taking
my question what is the difference
between this bill and the current
executive order that um the emergency
order that the governor enacted
thank you representative so that the key
objective for this bill
um and i'm i'm not directly answering
i'm gonna get there but i'm going to go
a little
wider is
to address the uncertainty around the
federal
eviction
um
ban through the cdc that's been extended
through march
and the uncertainty around um
the application of the kovid 19 relief
uh funded by congress
so we've got a number of different
programs that are intended to
keep people in their homes who have been
affected by kova 19
and
they don't always mesh particularly well
or there's uncertainty and the whole
point here is just just to give people
um the time and the
wherewithal to uh to use these programs
that are there specifically for this
purpose
um
so uh to the specifics of uh
i would i would leave it to another uh
person to maybe address that in
specifically but that is the objective
are you okay representative
um it's a follow-up if i could
thank you mr chair um so i i guess i'm
wondering because the governor's order
that's currently enacted has to be
renewed every 21 days due to the state
of emergency so this would just extend
it nine days
if this passed and it would expire at
the end of a state of emergency
so if once this bill goes through the
entire process of
um
like
passing a bill would this ability even
forgive me um
yes uh
so that i anticipated that question so
um
we don't know what's going to happen in
the future
and we certainly didn't know what was
going to happen with kova 19 relief and
with the cdc extension back when this
bill was filed uh that said um
this is just a way of ensuring
that those protections exist uh when we
have other things that are out of our
control this is something the
legislature can control uh and and
that's why i think it's important to
thank you
thank you any other questions for
sing none again thank you for your
testimony today
the next person to test it we only have
three other people who have signed up to
testify
berry thank you mr chairman uh
so very very briefly and i'm not sure i
understood if i may have misunderstood
uh representative alexander's question
but right now as to evictions there
there is no more any moratorium or any
relevant uh governor's order uh what we
have is the cdc moratorium on eviction
for non-payment of rent that expires on
march 31st
um
after march 31st we may have very
big big trouble
but
let me just tell you where the law is
right now right now if a tenant uh gets
an eviction notice for non-payment of
rent their right to pay and stay
expires after the the expiration of the
notice to quit there is no possible way
that somebody can apply to the for the
federal funds uh within the seven day
period to cure the non-payment i want to
be clear a landlord can't accept it
after that but they don't have to
what were what's being proposed here
um is right and and i'm sorry let me
also make clear the current status of
the relief fund the cares act funds that
were available to help tenants pay
rental arrearages uh due to copen that
has expired uh as f as of december 18
2020 tenants could not apply the new
federal program which is going to bring
a lot of money for this purpose into new
hampshire 200 million dollars for this
in the uk and utilities but that is not
close to up and running right now i'm
not even sure the state has received it
they haven't decided who's going to be
the administrator and it's going to have
more requirements than the cares program
did and in the cares program it took
generally around 45 days
for the applications to be processed and
and payment to be made so that extra
time that you need that
this bill provides for the tenants to to
pay
it doesn't stop the landlord from filing
the eviction it just provides more time
for the tenant to go through the process
and have a reasonable chance of getting
getting a grant that will solve
the problem for the tenant
it's a win-win situation
and i hope due to the
one last point
the it's true that the governor the
emergency period
only lasts for 21 days i think that's
right
but
the governor obviously has been renewing
these time and time and time again given
the status of covid right now i could
really i could see this don't the
emergency orders going well into the
fall
and if this moves through the
legislature
quickly it can certainly provide a lot
of relief for a lot of people
and that's what i got to say
seeing none thank thank you for your
testimony again this morning
and nick norman
very good thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak once again
i'll bypass introductions i know time is
short the landlord position on this bill
would be to be against the bill and to
vote to kill the bill
there are
an enormous amount of
programs that have come out in support
of
tenants getting assistance
and
seems to be never ending eviction
moratoriums
there's a overlapping of federal and
state
moratoriums and cdc moratoriums it is
getting very very confusing we don't
think that there needs to be anything
else to confuse the whole eviction
process
this is very late to the party
vaccines are coming out the 200 million
is coming out
there's
just lots of benefits
we have landlords that are suffering
from tenants that have not paid rent
since february of last year
it's just ridiculous
so
um
we would be opposed for it
and
uh
i should make something clear that maybe
is this confused by what elliot may have
just presented
there is a cdc eviction moratorium
presently
and the only thing a tenant has to do to
get protection
on that
is to present a cdc declaration just
present a piece of paper to the landlord
and by the ruling of the new hampshire
courts the entire eviction process has
so i don't think that we need to create
and i'm happy to take any questions
if not i think thank you for your
testimony mr norman
and the last person we have to testify
is ben mortal
but again alyssa margolin although
didn't didn't sign up but has her hand
i do mr chairman and i'm sorry i did
sign up this morning um albeit a little
bit after nine so perhaps i didn't make
your list thank you for hearing housing
action new hampshire's testimony we are
in support of house bill 550. our
coalition has been very involved in
helping secure housing stabilization
resources
we were really pleased when the
governor's office for emergency relief
and recovery stood up the new hampshire
housing relief program very early in the
pandemic and we were really an example
to other states in a step forward on
housing stability but as other uh
testifiers have noted it's a very
dynamic landscape there's currently no
uh state more uh torium on eviction
there is the cdc eviction moratorium
that's due to expire on march 31
there's the expiration of the
early relief program and the
anticipation of the new program created
by the relief bill passed in december
and of course we're all waiting to see
what happens in congress with the the
newest um
the newest proposal for relief
um we think that putting this kind of
policy in play would actually create
some needed
stability and understanding of the
process in a dynamic and ever-changing
landscape
there is some lag time between the time
a tenant
applies for
the um the relief and
then when the landlord is made whole
and of course we are counting on our
state agency partners to
vet these applications and be good
stewards of taxpayer resources
so we think this would be
good
to help us you know navigate
the landscape right now but also any
kind of state of emergency in the future
we really shouldn't create um housing
instability and we we shouldn't um
you know create uh homelessness when
tenants are simply just awaiting their
assistance we really shouldn't let
bureaucracy uh get in the way and just
having the courts hit pause for 30 days
um in order for our systems to respond
um thoughtfully it you know makes good
sense and therefore we recommend that
you pass house bill 550.
thank you are there any questions for ms
margalin
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony
and i believe that that
uh ends the list of those people who
wish to testify there were
a number of people who expressed
opinions there were 34
in advance of the hearing today there
were 34 in support and 18 opposed
and with that i'll close the hearing on
house bill 550
and uh i was told that people might
appreciate a break at some point in time
in the morning so
why don't we
re
take a brief recess and come back at
about a quarter of and give everybody an
opportunity to
refresh themselves
so we'll we'll reconvene at quarter of
okay i'll call the house judiciary
our next bill to be heard this morning
this is relative to the rental or shared
living facilities
the primary sponsor is representative
uh there are four people who have
testified to
uh testified four people who have signed
up to testify today and the primary
sponsor is representative frost
and representative frost would you like
to introduce your bill
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
my name is sherry frost i represent
dover's ward 4 stratford 16. being
mindful of the heavy workload that the
committee has this day i would introduce
the bill and with the chair's permission
we'll read into the record the testimony
of the community member on whose behalf
i submitted this bill
i understand that there are a couple of
attorneys who signed up to speak after
me who can clarify any questions that
you may have okay hb 360 is a bit of
housekeeping to clear up some ambiguity
in rental law that applies to shared
owner-occupied spaces so when an owner
rents a room to a tenant but the living
spaces are shared in common
specifically it requires that in the
event of a dispute the tenant must
disclose that the situation is a 540b
shared space rental and is not subject
to the remedies outlined in 540a
um i will happily email this
testimony to the committee
as soon as i'm done here uh jonathan
dowling of dover asked that this be
submitted into law and this is his
testimony
hb 360 needs to pass because it's
imperative that our rental laws clarify
a confusing situation for tenants
landlords and the courts
nhrsa 540b deals with owner-occupied
rentals these shared space rentals have
a tenant living in a room and sharing
common spaces such as a kitchen and or
bathroom
knowing the sensitivity of shared space
when things do not work out the statute
provides different procedures for
removal or eviction of a tenant
the problem is that many of the parties
do not have adequate knowledge of the
procedures in the 540b that differ from
a traditional rental property eviction
process this includes both the tenant
and the court
due to ambiguities in the law i lived in
a potentially dangerous shared space
even with a protective order given to me
by the court against the tenant i was
still told by the court to allow the
tenant to remain in the property for two
weeks after i took lawful possession
the issue was that after publicly
shaming me on social media the tenant
received incorrect advice and filed for
540a protections not once stating that
it was a shared space rental under 540b
the court then applied the typical
process and accused me of a lockout
after the tenant refused to participate
in the hearing a permanent protective
order was given to me and the tenant was
removed this was weeks after being
lawfully evicted the eviction that
followed all state laws and was served
by a third party
this measure
would clarify the process to protect
people who rent rooms and shared spaces
540b properties our state's eviction
laws are important to protect tenants
from disreputable landlords but they
also allow for bad faith by tenants who
abuse the system
requiring a tenant to state clearly the
type of property they are filing a 540a
petition for will inform the court if
tenancy laws have been followed more
clearly than currently and prevent a
tenant from abusing the situation
and in 540b properties protect landlords
trying to get out of a poor situation
courts would need to recognize that laws
differ and not to give temporary order
that may violate the 540p statute this
will also provide a penalty for filing
false information to the court thank you
and that's all i have
does that conclude you
okay
are there any questions for
seeing no questions thank you for your
testimony today
thank you
there are other people who have signed
up to testify today
and
one being
is attorney becker
available
if you could raise his hand i might be
able to find him yeah
being the case we'll move on to nick
norman
thank you very much again for the
opportunity to speak to the committee
this is i hopefully as you've just
noticed is very very simple bill it
actually doesn't change anything in the
existing law as we read it what it does
is it clarifies the existing law
makes it easier for courts to understand
looking to
to
to um
you know to adjudicate
we think that it would
make things simpler it would reduce
actions that should not even be
litigated reduce caseloads facilitate
quicker comprehension of the issues
before a judge
it's very reasonable to ask
a tenant to just state on a 540a
petition that they're in reshared
facility
and if if you think that it might be
confusing for attendant to know which
class of property he's in the court
forum could just be simply
to answer a couple questions and then
the the judge
and the court system would know which
that's really it for my testimony i
think it makes a lot of sense and it
doesn't change present law
i'd be happy to take any questions
singhan thank you for your testimony
the next person who signed up to testify
uh hello again again i can be very brief
here um i don't have a problem with the
concept of in this bill at all i should
say that i was one of the people who
negotiated what turned out to be rsa
540-b
i just want to make sure
that um
number one that you understand that this
is only applies to you you know to the
uncomfortable situation where the tenant
is re sharing part of the facility a
dining room a kitchen a bathroom with
the owner of the premises in that case
under the current law right now the
tenant uh the landlord nearly
merely needs to give three
seven or 30 days notice by just posting
it on the primary door uh to the rented
premises they do not after that expires
they don't have to go to court at all
but the current law says if the landlord
doesn't do that the tenant can bring an
action under rsa 540 a4 uh in order to
get back in until the notice requirement
is met um
i agree that there probably is a problem
here and all i would like to ask that
you do or let me just say one uh thing
to explain my position the
it is very rare for the tenant to have
any idea whether his or her occupancy is
regulated by rsa 540b they probably
don't even know what a shared facility
is under the law so all i would ask and
i've already in order to try to help
this along i emailed
with david king the chief judge of the
uh circuit court who did indicate to me
that he didn't see why the 540a form
could not be uh um
modified to
create the simple question that would
notify the judge and the tenant if
they're a 540b situation so all i would
ask is that maybe you insert something
in there that says upon
uh
uh upon forms created or uh created by
the court system but otherwise the
tenant who
who was un locked out without notice
will have no idea that he's supposed to
put down uh rsa 540b on the petition and
therefore will not get the relief that
the current statute requires but with a
simple amendment directing the court to
modify the form i don't have any problem
and again justice king told me i could
share with the committee uh that he
doesn't see why that can't be done
thank you
are there any questions for
um thank you very much mr chairman i'm
not sure if this is for mr berry or for
you but we have been given um a proposed
amendment uh by
representative frost it's 2021
0201 h and
representative frost did not
submit the amendment before the
committee all we have is a printed copy
and i before this hearing ended i wanted
to make sure that
if this should have been submitted to us
officially
that that happened
okay
thank you i i guess
we could
uh
uh well
i'll call upon uh representative frost
to address that
and but before i do that i'll just ask
if there are any other questions
xenon thank you mr oh no i uh
sorry i wasn't fast enough um so
according to mr barry then if a
different amendment was put in it would
eliminate the confusion
by saying there was a simple form
um is is someone going to um give us any
language for that said amendment or
yeah i could i mean i'll offer uh yeah
it's a very simple amendment but if um
if you would like me
to do so i can provide it to uh the
chairman or the whoever i'm supposed to
provide it to uh within 24 hours for
sure i just want to make sure that
i'm
straight on this because i was a little
confused
thank you thank you
thank you mr mr terrify might this is
representative frost um yes i was i was
approached by um
attorney barry and um
asked about this so we submitted a um i
i submitted the the amendment but then
it was decided that the the problem that
the amendment addresses can be taken
care of by that change in the form so
just a tick box on the form needs to be
fixed so that we we can we can throw the
amendment that you have in your hand out
and put a new one in that addresses the
form that the the tenants fill out
okay
and so the amendment that you had
previously submitted we can ignore
and you're not intending to go forward
with that but uh
mr barry you're going to be providing us
with the language for a another
amendment to address the issue which
you've addressed today
i would be happy to do so who should i
uh should i send it to you mr chairman
uh either me or i guess representative
smith would you like to take care of
that
i'd be happy to
okay if you could forward it either to
me or to representative smith i think
representative smith would take care of
that for you
thank you
mr chairman uh is it possible that all
members of the committee could be
favored with a copy of the amendment
yes
for sure before
anyone had an opportunity to vote on it
everybody will have a copy of the
amendment since i have not seen we'll
make sure that it's distributed i have
not make sure it's distributed to
everybody thank you i did not receive
the prior amendment that's now going to
um i i believe that the prior amendment
was sent to everybody on the committee
representative silver but if you are
like me you're drowning in emails and
sometimes it's hard to find
to make the connections with the
okay
and uh again thank you for your
testimony mr barry and thank you for
your indulgence not a problem at all and
is there anybody else who wishes to
testify today
i s deuce i i now see elite
attorney becker
on the
with the hand raised so attorney becker
i just wanted to testify today i i
worked with representative frost on the
crafting of this amendment i've had
several of these kind of unique
situations come forward in my practice
where a landlord
rents a room in their home
shares their home with an individual
and
right as
the landlord seeks to to
kind of terminate the tenancy things go
south very fast
these can become very volatile
situations as i think rsa 540b kind of
contemplates with the short termination
of tenancy process
and i think that this
this bill is important because
in my experience
there is some ambiguity in the law
um and it's misunderstood by a lot of
lay people landlords
tenants
the judiciary
um and law enforcement so it creates a
real headache for
landlords that are seeking to
terminate a tenancy and it can be a
okay
all right when you started off by saying
that you helped craft the
i helped craft the bill
okay thank you
for that
and
uh is there are there any questions uh
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you sir
um
i don't see anybody else who wishes uh
that to testify who hasn't testified
that i do see nick norman's hand up do
you are you asking to testify again mr
norman no i'm just asking to receive a
copy of the amendment that elliot is
preparing elliot and i've worked
together many many many times so
just like to
get a copy of that so you can see
the landlord's view on that before you
okay
uh
and
i'm not uh elliot are you going to send
him a copy or of what you're preparing
or
is that something that the committee is
or elliot i don't know if you're still
there
yes i'd be very happy to send it to nick
at the same time i send it to you all
that'd be great
okay
i don't see anybody else with a hand up
here so i'm going to close the hearing
on house bill
and which
believe it or not gives us time until
our next hearing is scheduled so
uh
everybody uh everybody realizes that uh
we we are going to apparently have
session on february 24th and 25th i did
send out an uh an email yesterday
hopefully you've all received that email
just
explaining what we're doing for the next
couple of weeks
and we do have a lot of bills i think we
have more bills than any other committee
to get through we're going to
be busy and i'm sure we're going to be
doubling up on weeks
with that if you want to take uh and
take another break we'll break until
[Music]
11 15.
thank you we'll recess until 11
so
guys
shhh
you
so
hello everybody i will reconvene the
house judiciary committee
our next bill to be heard this morning
is house bill 395 fn relative to
consideration of home share income
and exempting rentals of shared
facilities from requirements under the
real estate practice act
prime sponsor is representative
burroughs
and representative burroughs would you
um i don't see representative burroughs
on the attendee list
i know she was there earlier she has an
old uh version of zoom so i had to
promote her to a panelist she should be
she's on now um
mr chair i don't know if
it doesn't look like she's muted so
anita can you speak
i think the problem is that um
representative burroughs has a video
feed but it doesn't appear that she's
connected to audio
ah
so i don't i don't see a microphone for
you representative pearls um
and you would need to look at your audio
settings in the lower left
um
but
you
or you could you could also access the
meeting by telephone representative
pearls using um
this is
this is similar to what happened to uh
supreme court justice convoy last week
[Music]
perhaps what we could do is uh call upon
other speakers and then come back to
and perhaps she if she can't
have her
computer function to make that work
perhaps she could call in
mr chair i would be happy to introduce
the bill on uh representative burroughs
behalf
so that you have a formal introduction
and then um
we could get her
that that would be that would be fine i
would note that we have four people
including uh one who was uh represented
burroughs
uh wishing to speak but everyone was
speaking in support so
so
representative smith if you wanted to
just begin by introducing the bill that
would be fine
it's always a pleasure to appear before
the judiciary committee on behalf of the
prime
sponsor representative anita berth from
carroll county district one and a former
member of this committee i am pleased to
introduce three at 95 nn
fn
relative to consideration of home share
income and exempting rentals of shared
facilities from requirements under the
real estate practice act
and having introduced the bill i will
surrender the um
witness uh seat
in favor of others who have signed up to
thank you very much
and
we do as i indicated there are
other than representative burroughs
three other people who wish to speak and
there is will stewart
and mr stewart are you available to
speak
yes mr chairman can you hear me
we can
excellent so uh thank you for allowing
me to speak today
mr chair members of the committee for
the record my name is will stewart i'm
the executive director of stay work play
new hampshire and we're a statewide
non-profit whose mission is to attract
and retain more young people here in the
grand state
i am here today to speak in favor of
hospital 395.
so
attracting and retaining more young
people you know really is critical to
the future of new hampshire we are at
present the second oldest state in the
country with one of the lowest
unemployment rates and on top of this
we're the number one exporter of high
school graduates seeking a four-year
degree with some 62 percent of these
young people leaving the state every
year some eventually come back but many
don't in short new hampshire needs all
the people we can get in general and all
the young people we can get in
particular our businesses need workers
and customers our towns need volunteer
board members our non-profits churches
and civic clubs all need volunteers to
accomplish their vital missions without
which our communities just can't
function so
about three years ago state workplace
commissioned a survey to collect data on
why young people stay in new hampshire
and why they might leave and the number
one reason we found
young people leaving is that they can't
afford to live here our housing on both
the rental and home ownership sides is
just too expensive and we heard this
again and again and again uh last fall
and winter as we were out talking to
young people in nine locations across
the state as part of our policy and
pints series
so you know housing in new hampshire is
expensive for everyone
but it's especially expensive expensive
for young people who by being early in
their careers generally make less money
than their more experienced counterparts
young people also face the additional
burden of student loan debt indeed here
in new hampshire we have one of the
highest student loan debts uh debt loads
in the country and when you're paying
hundreds of dollars in student loan
payments each month on top of a car
payment it makes it that much harder to
afford housing that's already uh pretty
expensive and so it's network play we're
in support of this bill because uh you
know it seeks to remove some of the
disincentives to home sharing and uh you
know this is a way we can continue to
try to make new hampshire housing and
new hampshire just a little bit more
affordable for young people and everyone
for that matter
you know home sharing is just a small
part of the overall housing
affordability solution that could be but
one that can be implemented immediately
and really at no cost to anyone as it
doesn't require new housing to be
designed cited approved or constructed
so for these reasons we are in support
stay work play is in support of house
bill 395 and we appreciate your
consideration of bill as well thank you
thank you thank you for your testimony
thank you for your testimony
representative gordon
representative burroughs has connected
by telephone
okay
representative burroughs
can you hear us
griffin bros you'll just have to unmute
can you hear me now
yes we can representative burroughs
welcome back to the
sorry so sorry i actually signed it hour
early so i wouldn't have any problems
and there you have it so um thank you
thank you for affording me this
opportunity um to testify in this bill
and i apologize because i missed um what
the previous speaker was saying so i
hope i don't repeat myself
i'm not going to reiterate um my written
testimony just to give you a little bit
background about how this came to be um
this the home share actually started up
in the mount washington valley
because we have
we have a lot of people particularly
seniors who have may have a large home
or plenty of space and
despite having a big home may need
additional income or may simply want
company or want want roommates who might
be able to help with snow plowing and uh
even food shopping and preparing meals
so that's how this came about um it was
the program was modeled um on a a
simpler program in vermont and it is
applicable not just for the mount
washington ballot but to across the
state um it was put on hiatus um because
of covert um but um i i believe somebody
will be tested mary and dr marion
jackson will be testifying um that
there's been increasing interest in the
program uh once once covered it becomes
safe to do for so cause we have so many
people coming to the valley to help out
in the hospitality industry and the ski
industry and this would really be
helpful um and
i personally know of a number of people
who are in this situation who either
need can't find housing they're forced
to live an hour away in berlin or in
brownfield maine um even nurses can't
find housing here so it will be very
helpful um although it's not gonna to um
solve the housing sort this housing
shortage um this bill was um put
together hb 1305 in 1324 from 2020. both
those bills passed through um committee
um unanimously and because the covert
got way late so um the two bills were
put together the first part of the bill
would exempt income from a home share
arrangement from the determination of
net assets for the purposes of
determining eligibility for certain
property tax exemptions
exemptions and public eligibility
determination and the second part would
not would serve to not categorize these
transactions as a real estate
transaction
and to
exempt them from licensure and
regulation by the new hampshire real
estate commission and i'll talk to that
one very briefly and first to say that
um
both the
real estate association and the
professional licensing bureau are
neutral
in terms of this part of the bill
and the reason it's to be exempt is
because the home share actually takes
over a lot of the functions of um that
the realtors previously did
the people are screened by the home
share program
they're then brought together and they
do their own their own form of beliefs
they put that together themselves so
that's taking it out of the hands of the
the real the realtors and um and it's
really unnecessary because again the
parties involved are the ones who um
who make that come to the agreement um
in reading the bill for the hundredth
time i um i saw something that i think
actually probably um should be changed
and just written the wording
um
it talks about um
that some of the home share uh folks may
receive um or reduce rent in exchange
for chores and i'm not sure that that
needs to be in the bill because not
everybody not everybody um has that type
of arrangement some people just just
come in and they rent the space and the
um owner does not need or want tours or
that kind of thing so it's it's it's a
it's a nice to have but um not everybody
um who is involved in this practice um
will do so so um again i i've already
given testimony and and in the i know i
have to 115 to speak but i will i will i
will ease your mind and i will not be
doing that and i will stop and ask
questions
okay representative sylvia did you have
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh i see the term in
here home chair but i don't see it
defined anywhere in the statutes is that
um
i i don't we don't have a specific um
um definition of it but i think it's i i
think in the name itself is pretty it
pretty um explains it you're sharing
you're sharing your home with somebody
in this case you know we're targeting um
workers and and
either individual workers or families
and to my knowledge the program that was
initiated
in the mount washington valley was the
first of its kind
they suggested that we not
um specifically talk to that in the
language of the bill but just make it
thank you
and representative burch
thank you mr chair and and thank you
representative burroughs it's good to
see you here
in judiciary again
um
for those of us who are not
sophisticated about these issues
i want to follow up your answer that you
just gave because i'm wondering about
the target
of
this legislation i hear
affordable housing i hear
seniors
but i'm wondering whether the target of
this legislation is really
because
the
valley is a big ski area
and these are people perhaps
would this allow
uh people who want to allow who want to
have
other skiers come and have
14 people in their uh homes renting
and exempt them from any kind of state
regulation uh no
no
just to finish how would this
not apply to that
um it doesn't it doesn't at all
representative burch um this is not this
is not for first of all there is an
agreement involved um that is a long a
longer term rental um so it's not it's
not for a week or
six months it is it is specifically um
for people to to have a home so no it is
not targeting skiers and this would not
be applicable to them and the home share
program
the one that is set up in the mount
washington valley would not entertain
those types of agreements at all in in
the in the they do the matchmaking and
they would not entertain that
you have a follow-up
representative
i'm just wondering if there's anything
in the bill
that would keep
um this from happening
no there isn't but i think we'd be open
to adding a clause if you feel that that
would be important to do so
representative alexander
um thank you mr chair and uh thank you
to my former colleague on judiciary for
taking my question
um my question is or my question concern
is around not defining the term home
share
because we've heard a lot of
testimony today about landlord right
tenant rights all that jazz and i guess
are we going to run into the trouble
that we're running in right now with the
other bills that we're discussing by not
actually defining what home share is in
statute
i think that you know frank i think that
would be for the committee to um
to discern um i i personally think that
that you know
the home share is clear but you know
again would intert would be happy to
entertain i'm putting a definition of
okay
thank you mr chairman i had i had
lowered my hand because representative
alexander had kind of covered it but um
speaking to representative burch's point
i think i think his point is again why
we need a definition of home chair
also
now i appreciate that i i actually i i i
you're muted representative chase i
think
hello
hello can you hear me we can hear you
now okay sorry i'm having difficulties
with this new computer
thank you again and
uh representative burroughs what exactly
is the criteria for long term did you
state that is it a year is it three
years six months that
that's a good question representative
chase that actually will depend on the
two parties and what a lot of people do
like in the vermont um in the scenario
of the vermont agency that this is
modeled on oftentimes people will do a
trial run maybe 30 60 days and then they
decide the beauty of this program is
that the two parties decide what they
want to do and what kind of arrangement
they want to make
but
again the agency the again in this case
is the gibson center will not entertain
um scenarios where their skiers are
looking for a place to stay for for a
couple of weeks
to get a cheap rent that kind of thing
could i follow up with that
you may thank you very much and uh okay
so then that makes me wonder about those
people what if they go in there with the
pretense if they're just going to rent
for the winter season or for
a couple of months and it's on a trial
basis are there going to be regulations
for that so it's not the
keep picking on skiers but people that
are just going up there to recreate
well they're good they're going to have
to go through this screening process so
it would be a lot of work
for them to to go through this pretense
to get to get that and it's not like
they're going to get cheap digs
you know so there you know there is a um
again the one the re some people say
well why don't you just do this on
craigslist well craigslist doesn't go
through screening it doesn't do criminal
background track check which is one of
the things the program does so they'd
have to go through a heck of a lot of
work um just to get lodging and i don't
think it would be worth their while to
do it
all right thank you very much
thank you for taking my question um
good morning representative burroughs
it's great to see you i have a couple of
questions um
and one is how is this arrangement
different from a rooming house
oh okay well i think i think the main
differential here is the screening
process again um and there may be
programs that are going to be set up in
different parts of the state so right
now the gibson center being the only one
that i know of i can only speak to that
but um
it's not a rooming house because because
there you know there's this again it's
the screening it's the criminal
backgrounds check and ultimately the two
parties do agree upon what the terms are
but there's a lot of background that
goes into it that might not happen with
a rooming house scenario so it also
provides the safety net for a senior who
may be concerned about who's coming into
their home and they have secure some
security knowing that the person um
doesn't have a criminal record you know
not involved with drugs that kind of
thing
thank you may i ask a second question mr
chair
may i ask a second question mr chair
you certainly may okay thank you um
representative burroughs
my question is around fitness for
um human habitability
um and housing code
regulations is our home share
that is an excellent question
um and i don't know
i i'm going to leave if you don't mind
dr jackson i believe will be on the call
and she could better answer that in
terms of what they do if there's any
inspection and what they do in terms of
that so i would like to defer that
question to her if you don't mind thank
any other questions for representative
burroughs yes
thank you mr chairman sorry bear with me
because again this is all new to me so
i'm i'm curious is there some sort of a
certificate that comes along with this
what's to prevent
people from having
10 people in their homes with these
rooms how do they prove that this was
through the home share program and not
that they just
um rented rooms am i missing something
i'm not sure i i'm not sure how to
answer that question because again
you've got a signed agreement between
two parties
you know let's let's just say mary smith
wants to rent to to
you know
um
donna
and they signed an agreement and if
donna was to show up with 10 people
she'd have you would do what you did
would do in a in any other scenario you
would you would um
the agreement would not be being
followed and you would have cause to to
remove them from the home
up mr chairman you may i'm sorry i don't
i don't think i phrased my question
correctly
so say my neighbor
tells me they're in this home share
thing
and they have
that are actually going weekly but
they're telling me
that it's through the home share program
this from being abused when there's not
a formal agreement with that home shared
thing am i making any sense
yeah no i understand what you're saying
and again the home share the agency
would not in any way facilitate
that type of arrangement so let's just
say donna then i mean i'm sorry i think
i said sue was the homeowner if sue goes
out on her own and fills the rooms up um
she's that is something outside the
boundaries of the home share
and i don't think the agency could could
be liable for that or responsible for
that
could i just follow up on that
if as i look at the bill
does the bill require that this be done
through an agency
and
and uh there are other questions for
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
can i come back to judiciary
and i i wish connection was where
we're always glad to have you back
judiciary thank you thank you okay our
next person
the next person to testify will be
[Music]
representative mclean do you
you see her on the
witness list no i don't see her if she
could raise her hand maybe that would
don't see her no i'm afraid i don't see
her sir
and
okay and the other person is harrison
kansler
mr kansler yes thank you so much uh mr
chair um i spoke with you all right i
just want to start by saying i spoke
with you all earlier um
representing the mount washington valley
housing coalition and i just want to
state for the record that i am not
representing the mount washington valley
housing coalition in this testimony i am
just a member of the public um in fact i
am acting as a former representative i
served carroll county district 2 during
the last last session and i was
one of the co-sponsors on these bills
and i was the lead sponsor on the real
estate portion of the bill and so i did
want to just um follow up actually um
before i give my testimony on some of
the questions you all have been
mentioning
um this is a complicated um topic
that there is
some definition in statute um home share
is in reference to the rental of shared
facilities shared facilities are defined
in rsa 540b
a shared facility is real property
rented for residential purposes which
has separate sleeping areas for each
occupant and in which each occupant has
access to and shares with the owner of
the facility one or more significant
portions of the facility in common this
would be something like a kitchen a
dining area or a bathroom
um so just i know that that was kind of
a concern a lot of you had raised so i
just wanted to note that that is what
home share is it would fall under um
that i believe it would fall under that
definition that was my understanding
when i worked with
ols last year
[Music]
by that definition
um
that i think answers some of the other
questions you had as well each occupant
must have their own sleeping facility so
as far as having you know 10 people in
one room that would not count that would
just be called airbnb and we see it all
the time up here
in fact if you want to regulate that i
would please let me know
because it is currently not regulated
really um but no this this is um this is
just a program wherein um specifically
elderly folk
can work with um can come to an
agreement
with some other folks um and they're
brought together
through this program so how the home
share program facilitates this is
essentially they take in homeowners they
do a
personality profile test with them um
they take kind of you know what what
they're offering as a living facility
and what they're looking for for
compensation sometimes it's purely
monetary sometimes there's no money
involved at all could as as
representative burrows uh suggested it
could just be you know shoveling the
walkway on a day like today or something
of that nature you know taking helping
take care of the facility
um
and what the home share program then
also does is reaches out to potential
tenants who come in and do the very
similar you know personality test um and
they work with them in that regard and
then what they do is it's it's very much
like a dating app they basically say hey
you two are a compatible match get
together they have um lease agreements
that are examples that the that the
homeowner can look at but ultimately
whatever compensation is decided upon
whatever agreement is decided upon is
between those parties and the home share
program does not actually facilitate
that transaction all they do is pair
them together
um
so that that's how that piece works um
and just to give you some ideas on on
that elderly piece again um carroll
county it was already stated that new
hampshire is one of the oldest states in
the country by mr stewart carroll county
where this would be operating is is one
of the oldest counties in the state and
one of the most rapidly aging
aarp actually did a study
um looking specifically at rural
communities and in elderly communities
in rural areas they found that 72
percent of of retirees in rural
communities said that they want
what they'd really like is to remain in
their community as long as possible and
said that not only do they want to
remain in their community but they want
to remain in their current residence
this bill
would allow for programs uh nonprofit
programs who want to operate this
matching system
to operate within our state
and so that is why um
i wanted to give you all my testimony i
sent you a written testimony that really
gets into the weeds on kind of the real
estate aspect of it i won't go into that
detail um unless you would like me to
and i'm open to any questions and um
though i am not representing the the
mount washington valley uh housing
coalition in this testimony i do know
that they support this bill if if that
we can't hear you
sorry
yeah
question this sounds like this is all
what you're talking about is going
through an agency our representative
borough said that it's not required to
be done through an agency so how would
um
would that mean there would be no
matching and
if someone did not go through an agency
they're doing it on their own and how
was that regulated
would you still be aware that they're
trying to use this um this homeowner's
sharing arrangement
well so to the best of my understanding
i've got a spare room in my house and as
a homeowner i'm perfectly within my
legal rights to rent it out to
whomsoever i choose
um for whatever compensation i deem
necessary um so what what the home so i
mean that is
not regulated because it's my right as a
homeowner to to rent that space out
again what the focus here is on is what
the program does um if i do that you
know if i decide to rent it out
unilaterally without the assistance of
any program
i am now having to do any sort of
background checks i'm having to hope
that this person through a few meetings
is someone who i'm gonna become i have
two very young children in my house i
have to be comfortable with my children
being around this person on a regular
basis right so what the home share
program does
is is it covers those bases right it it
acts as the again as that kind of that
personal liaison to ensure that this
person is going to
fit within your household
and is going to fit with you on a social
basis so so again this this doesn't have
anything to do with regulating whether
or not i can have someone in my home
because i can do that under state law as
much as i want
it's what it what it is doing is saying
that this program can function so that
the elder people who have units
available in their homes feel more
comfortable opening their doors to allow
young professionals ideally in our areas
to stay in new hampshire work in new
hampshire
thank you yup
thank you mr chairman so
is this home share
program already in the works
so it it was um it started they have
gone through the process of there's i
believe a website that has some some uh
documents on it that people can use
however prior to it actually being
enacted
it was put on hiatus due to the coveted
pandemic
so the plan is that if we can get this
legislation put into place that would
allow it to function on on a regular
basis that once
things ideally return to a place where
you all can be in your big comfy
committee chairs um then we can also
look at you know potentially having this
functioning um
again within our community
yes you may yes
um so
the other part of this bill that we
don't seem to be talking about is the
property
liable to taxation hi please explain
this to me and how this is going to work
because i think this goes back to my
my question regarding the certificate
how did they prove to the town if
they're looking for a tax break on their
property taxes is that correct
correct yeah so so
you bring up an excellent point so what
this would be is obviously if
if they have done this proper if they've
done this through the program through
the home share program then the home
share program has record that
whatever income they are receiving
they are getting because of this program
because they are offering a a
i don't know as much about this
potentially as representative burroughs
but i will do my best in in saying that
essentially again the target audience
for the home sharer the person who's
opening their door
is the retired community is the elderly
community in our area many of them are
on fixed incomes and there are quite a
few who are looking for some sort of tax
abatement or are on some sort of program
that is keyed specifically to their
income
so what we were trying to ensure is that
them opening their doors and helping our
community by making a rental unit
available
would not hinder their ability to have
access to these programs or to that
abatement that they need based on their
fixed income
thank you
representative alexander
um thank you mr chair um
representative rice asked kind of a
question that i just want to follow up
on um this specific home share program
is not defined in statute
correct like the program that you're
outlining correct so the the program
itself is not defined what it
facilitates which is the rental of a
shared facility is defined the shared
mr chair yes
yes please thank you
um so my question being is
the
situation you outlined with your spare
room
um would you be able to
through this bill actually qualify for
the tax abatement status because it's
not technically outlined that it's
specifically to this program
um that's that is a very good question
um
i don't i can't speak to that um again i
think
how
how this is worded it's saying that if
the income is coming from home share um
i would the onus would be on me to
defend that this was in fact some sort
of home sharing that i was doing and so
that is where the program would come
into play because they could say yes
this was facilitated through our home
share program as opposed to me saying
yeah i'm home sharing i just you know
put this room up on craigslist and
someone came in because that is a lot
more just like subletting a room out of
thank
representative alexander kind of asked
my question it's it's along the same
lines
thank you
representative oregon
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much uh
former evidence counselor it's a
pleasure to have you back um
this
may be a dumb question but the the
intent of this is to exclude you know
from the net assets and so forth not
just
uh
there's obviously first of all the uh
you know the
value of the in-kind services that the
home chair is providing for the uh i
guess typically an elderly or disabled
person but also to um
exclude the
cash rent that the uh
home sharer is also paying to the uh
you know their host to their landlord or
whatever you want to call them
uh correct yes and and
yeah and and to the to the earlier point
i mean i you know
we would i i'm sure i don't i don't know
i can't speak for representative
burroughs if you all wanted to come up
with a definition specifically of home
sharing and amend that into the bill i
don't see as as we would necessarily
have an issue with it um obviously we
would be happy i i would be happy i'm
sure um dr jackson i don't know if she
has joined or not um and i'm sure
representative burroughs would all be
happy to work with you on um kind of
what that definition would look like to
ensure that programs that are operating
in good faith to serve their communities
would still be able to function under
whatever that definition is um so we're
not i'm
i mean so again it's not my bill anymore
but i wouldn't be opposed to that
definition being added
all right thanks
are there any other questions for former
representative kansler
see then thank you for your testimony
thank you so much
i'm looking at the list of attendees i
do not see
uh
dr jackson
um
i do see
uh
miss burroughs having a hand up
uh so representative burroughs is it
i think you have two
devices going at the same time guys
um represent bruce if you unmute your
telephone if you're still connected by
um if you press star six represent
burrows
okay
is there any
anybody else who wishes to testify
[Music]
signed up earlier this morning but after
the regis uh
the registration sheet was printed
okay
yes i would
please go ahead
sure thank you very much good morning
house judiciary committee members thank
you for the opportunity to testify today
my name is jim michaud i am testifying
in my capacity as chief assessor for the
town of hudson as a practitioner in
hampshire assessment administration
uh neither currently in favor nor
against i'm also chair of the new
hampshire association of assessing
officials legislative committee but i'm
not representing them on this either
i guess my first question is this bill
going to missile and county because it
i do not believe that it is
okay thank you thank you mr chair
um
my comments are only in regards to
sections one two and three of this bill
proposal
i believe that the intent is to shield
income in a home share arrangement
situation
to shield that residential apartment
bedroom rental income from being
considered for purposes of the elderly
disabled and deaf property tax
exemptions
if that is the case
the change in law is misplaced
it seeks to bar that income from being
considered as an asset
however
assessing officials are not and would
not be counting that income as an asset
in the first place
as income is not an asset it's well it's
it's income
um the rsa that they would want to
insert this into
um there's three separate rsas
for the elderly disabled and deaf
and there's areas in those where income
is described
currently there's only three exclusions
from income for purposes of all three of
those exemptions
are
life insurance paid in the death of an
insured
number two expenses and costs incurred
in the course of conducting a business
enterprise
and three proceeds from the sale of
assets this would now add a fourth
exclusion
um
so i i think uh as it's currently worded
i would not be excluding the income in a
home share arrangement if this were to
pass as it's worded
um i do have statutory references um i
can email those separately
beyond that
there's an rsa 72 colon 27-a
and that is the statutory mechanism by
which municipalities
modify and adopt property tax exemptions
and credits
one of the areas section 4
says
an amendment to a statutory provision
listed in paragraph one paragraph one of
that statute deals with exemptions and
credits
an amendment to a statutory provision
shall apply in municipality which
previously adopted the provision only
after the municipalities complies with
the procedure in this section in other
words
let's say
this bill is modified so it's in the
right area
and then it's passed into law
it wouldn't apply in hudson
until we've re-adopted our elderly or
disabled we don't have a deaf but until
we re-adopted them
and ancient may
is pretty clear on this direction to
municipalities
so
i just want to make sure that people
understand this doesn't just apply to
the 200 plus municipalities just because
it's adopted
um
i up another comment is i want to make
sure the dra retains rulemaking ability
uh to possibly provide some direction on
this uh to municipalities
it may already be in the overall rsa 72
i believe that is uh
is the ex
one other thing a definition of home
share arrangement um that would be very
helpful with municipalities so we can
fairly and equitably uh and consistently
from municipality to municipality apply
this this change um
that is that is all thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
yes representative smith
thank you mr chair um i wonder if mr
michelle would agree to submit
detailing his concerns and including the
specific rsa
references
um
it would be very helpful if he could do
that and do it very quickly so that we
could review that
perhaps in time to consider any
i would be glad to do that
thank you very much thank you mr chair
be much appreciated
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
and was there anyone else who wished to
testify
i don't see anyone
and so
i'll declare the hearing on house bill
closed and that completes our morning
agenda
and thank everybody for their
cooperation
and we will recess and reconvene at one
o'clock
thank you everyone
so representative gordon
i'm just putting together an email
updating the afternoons lists it looks
like there's only one entry since this
morning
and that's for
hb124 so that'll pop up in your inbox in
it's okay if i um
i have a question on whether it's for
the chair or the clerk or for jen but um
about uh we got red testimony in regard
for the prime sponsor of cacr10 but he
sent it in uh
an open office uh text format which um
i can read but i think probably many of
the people members of the community
probably most of them don't have open
office so like um i did send him an
email suggesting that he save it as a
that's not we don't have to worry about
that one until three o'clock but i
sorry can you hear
me now
a little
hello
all right i'll call this
did the chair abandon us did we do
i think he has technology issues
yes
i guess that's what happens when you
live in a third world country i'm making
the united states yeah
we missed you mr chair
yes uh
you can hear me good yes
well i'm gonna call this meeting of the
i'm gonna call this meeting of the house
no it's the same dead spot i've had all
morning
if you turn off your video you're going
to leave your sound might come through
better
well he's coming through fine now and he
how's that
good
okay
that can't be
this needs all the bandwidth for your
voice
okay
i think there's a computer going in the
other room i'm just going to shut that
are we working any better now
sounds good
be
okay
i'll call this meeting of the house
lost you again
gordon you keep going in and out
representative schmidt available to
testify
um rep representative smith
there we go somebody gave me the option
to unmute that's perfect hi this is this
is representative jen schmidt good
afternoon everybody
um
may i begin
revenue schmidt if you're only when
okay
yeah we can hear you okay thank you very
much and thank you mr chairman and
honored members of the committee for the
record my name is jan schmidt and i
represent ward 1 in nashua and today i
bring you hb 124 adopting the uniform
real property transfer on death act
now like any bill i've ever contemplated
for this committee i believe i had a
very simple request when i began
and i found out that there was a very
good reason for it to never have been
done before it's a really complicated
issue
but of course it's for a good cause all
the
t's need to be crossed and all the eyes
need to be dotted
um
last fall i received an email from a
constituent maureen franklin who will
probably want to speak later
that when speaking with her attorney she
had told
she'd been told that new hampshire
unlike many states had not added this
into their laws as yet
when i discussed this with ols
researcher
director padden she mentioned that this
had been part of a much larger attempt a
few years ago and the bill had died
simply due to the multiple complex
issues that it involved so we narrowed
it down
uh
from that much larger issue into
something
well at least more directed if not more
simple
what it means to do it means to adopt
the uniform real property transfer on
death act
uh to provide a mechanism for
non-probate transfer of land done by
permitting owners of interest in real
property to execute and to record a
transfer on death deed
so what this means for for her in
particular is that
not probate and setting up a trust could
be avoided and therefore be less
expensive and a faster method of dealing
with a disposition of real property
now uh the bill itself is in
incredibly complex i'm sure this is
something that you are
probably quite familiar with in this
committee uh complex bills and the
language that's absolutely necessary to
make it clear
but that is all i have uh but i'd be
willing to answer any questions anyone
else might have
[Applause]
should we wait for the chair or shall i
just identify
mr chair are you having a technical
problems again could you raise your hand
if you are
yes i i am oops
fading in and out
i'm having technical problems
so perhaps representative representative
mclaren
okay uh
i'll i'll take over for now then mr
chair until you get yourself sorted out
thank you and then you can you can raise
your hand when you think you're ready to
take back over
so with that
i'll open up i'll open up the
uh thank you mr chair and and thank you
representative for taking my question
in order uh
that i don't have to go through a line
by line which i have really no interest
in doing
do you can you tell us
whether your proposed bill
uh varies in any way
from the uniform real property transfer
on death act as approved by the
uniform law commission is it
exactly the same or are there changes
from what i understand from
director patton that is exactly where
she got this information from line by
line
representative
paul who did you say approve that
there's something uh am i still on
there's something called the uniform uh
uh
law commission
and new hampshire has representatives
they have representatives from a lot of
states and they try to put together
uniform legislation applicable to all
states but they would have to be adopted
by each individual state
so these are it's model legislation
and uh my understanding is this
particular model legislation has been
adopted by about half the states
representative macbeth
thank you um
is is this a taxable transfer
all the transfer is
i do not i do not see tax listed at all
representative silber
uh thank you mr chairman uh i have a
couple of questions
uh unfortunately as a lawyer i guess i
have to go through word by word
uh
on page two
line
uh
i'm sorry
um
i'm sorry page
page one line twenty eight
transfer on death deed revocable a
transfer on death deed is revocable even
if the deed or other instrument contains
a contrary provision the question is
i think this would go to court don't you
yes
the other question i have is
has this has the new hampshire bars real
property probate and trust loss section
of which i am a member
taken a position on this bill
i have not inquired
and has the dra taken a position as to
whether or not one of these deeds would
be subject to the real estate transfer
tax
again i have not inquired
thank you thank you for taking my
questions certainly
representative alexander
um thank you mr vice chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
from what i understand the federal debt
tax is um properties over um 11.2
million in value are subject to a
federal debt tax would this affect that
at all on the federal like coming from
since probate is avoided
and the
transfer on death is
clearly to be executed
on death
i'm not sure i'm not being a lawyer i'm
representative alexander do you have a
follow-up
representative silver
this is what's called a transfer with
retained life interest
it does not get the property value out
of the taxable estate no matter what the
title shows it's still under federal
estate tax law uh part of gross estate
well thank you representative i
appreciate that and i love your
background i've read every one of these
books
someone else
does anybody else have any questions for
representative
schmidt okay
um
i think
so we'd be looking for maureen uh
franklin who is the constituent who uh
is requesting this is she waiting in the
waiting room
um i have a maureen so i'll allow you to
can you hear me okay this is a new
platform for me
i think you can go ahead maureen oh
thank you very much and thank you for
hearing me
um i'm a widowed senior citizen
um with no children
i live in nashua
i bought my home in 2009
previously in another state
um i was pulling together my documents
for
when i died
um and went to three different attorneys
and found that the documents that i
needed
would cost me about thirty five hundred
dollars
i'm only on social security
i make well under thirty thousand
dollars a year
my house does not approach 11 million
dollars
it's probably worth about 250 000
the reality is that i cannot nor do i
really need
a trust
um
so
i looked into this because having lived
in other states we did have a transfer
on death
um law
my understanding is there were 38 states
that now have this type of legislation
and
what i'm what i'm trying to do
is pass my house along when i pass
i don't want extended relatives to go
through probate
i know that
it should make it simpler
but sometimes it doesn't
and it's not clear to me
why i should have to buy
pay for a probate pay for a trust
um
when i have nothing except my house
and i really i do understand if you've
got 11.9 million dollars
yes maybe your property is is subject to
a lot of different taxes
but
i've been a school teacher my whole my
whole life
um
and basically i can't understand and i
do know attorneys need to make money so
anybody that's an attorney no no um
no insult to you at all
but
i can't understand why i can't just pass
my house along without going through
this expensive
process
so i look to you and i ask i obviously
don't know
all of the laws
my understanding from my tax attorney
who's not an intern who's not a probate
attorney
is that there's no ramifications in
terms of my level
of income
for property tax or estate tax
so i guess that's all i have to say i
ask you please to support this
and that's it new hampshire is live free
or die so i don't know why we have to
have a trust here
thank you very much and you all have a
good afternoon
okay thank you miss franklin for your
thank you for taking my question mr vice
chair and my question is addressed to
miss franklin yesterday
is your house um is there a mortgage on
your house or do you own a free employer
i own it free and clear and i'm very
proud of that i worked many many years
to do that
okay
are there any other questions from ms
franklin
um that's the last person that i have on
my list but um i think um
there was another person that was coming
in on 124.
uh is there anybody else would like to
okay
with that i'll i'll close the hearing on
hb
and uh our next hearing doesn't start
for 10 minutes
so we'll recess until 1 30 and then
we'll take up hb 126.
thank you everybody have a great
afternoon thank you thank you
[Applause]
um
mclean can you hear me now
i apologize for the difficulties i just
went out of the old
zoom and created a new one in order to
participate
great
i've not heard back from the
office yet with regard to february
um 17th
hoping that i will hear today as to
whether or not that may be available
if it is that we'll schedule hearings
that day
and we'll have
a hearing on the 23rd tuesday the 23rd
as a regular hearing day
and then
we expect to be in session on the 24th
and 25th
so there'd be one hearing that week
and then with the following weeks if
we're able to have two hearing days a
week we'll do that until we can get
on the 16th we will have an executive
session and as i said in my email
yesterday if you plan to bring
amendments you should have them prepared
in advance and circulate them to the
committee
so that you'll be we'll be prepared to
discuss them on that afternoon
and we'll get we need to get out our
five early bills that day
one of which we've already addressed
which was the bill with regard to the
retirement benefits for judges
we retained that bill but there are four
others that we need to get out that day
and we'll get done
so
and then i'd plan to schedule an
executive session
we'd have two
two days of hearings and then
and then on the next hearing day have an
afternoon for executive session so that
we can try to keep up and get out our
and next week we do have
all of the
abortion reproductive rights related
bills
and i put them together
with the two days so that we can uh
address them
and uh
early in the session two of them are
early bills anyway but it seems that
they all involve the same subject matter
and we should take care of them
there are two
there the 6 22 and 625 the two early
bills deal with the same subject matter
really and that's with regard to
a time frame
after which it would be
abortion will be prohibited so i've
scheduled the hearings on those uh
contemporaneously
and
and that's so because i'm sure
the same people would speak on both
bills
dealing with the same subject matter so
we will hear those in the morning
on next tuesday
and then a separate bill
i think it's the bill with regard to the
centers and we'll deal that with that in
the afternoon
and then the next day there are two
bills again we'll be heard
contemporaneously on the 10th
and i scheduled them together because
they both deal with the same issue and
that is public funding uh for abortion
and so again we'd have the same speakers
i think on both bills so i hear both
bills together
and then the
sixth abortion goal here in the
afternoon
i have to say i've been very pleased
with the attendance that are
hearings and particularly the attendance
today
everyone being remote and everybody
participating
and no one having to shovel out their
driveways
well when we're done here today i'll be
snowblowing
i wait for the snow to milk
[Laughter]
representative smith if you want me to
drive to durham to clear your driveway i
will do that you let me know
representative alexander that is so kind
of you i really appreciate it but i
don't think it's necessary i don't go
anyplace anyway
and since i know
that representative alexander
is not a sexist in the slightest you're
welcome to come to west milan and do my
driveway
okay a little bit of a further trip out
there though representing me
representative alexander but i'm not
representative alexander this goes to
show you that no good deed goes
unpunished
well my understanding is that we can
start the hearing
early as long as the hearing is still
continuing
at the
that the appointed time
i don't
yes okay
so
we do have house bill 126 which is
relative to notice of execution of tax
lien to mortgagees
and
is the prime sponsor here
well i'm looking
prime sponsors representative cahill yes
sir
i'm here
and representative cahill is here so why
don't we call upon representative cahill
uh thank you very much mr chairman
members of the committee
um
unlike my
the previous uh member of labor
committee jan schmidt i i bring you a
very simple bill
and um it's we're going to change one
line and hb1 in the legislation it's at
line four
we're going to increase the
the number of days uh the deadline from
45 to 60.
why would we want to do that you may ask
there's not enough time now there are
only a couple of people that are doing
this work with the
200 plus towns that need to have it done
and uh i while i'm not proficient in in
this area my uh this my constituent who
asked me to uh
to sponsor this bill is waiting in the
wings that would be uh jane sanders uh a
former tax tax collector and now she
does this tax lien research
a co-sponsor on this bill i'm not sure
she's able to testify today
rep
de simone is a current tax collector and
i understand the bill has the support of
the municipal association and the tax
collectors association
and i i did have a call from the bankers
and
they saw no objection to this so this
race should be very very simple
and with that i conclude my testimony
thank you represented by their questions
xenon thank you for your testimony thank
you representative uh silver had a
question oh representative silver okay
is am i correct in reading that the only
change is in line four changing 45 to 60
days
that is correct sir
seeing none then i'll call upon
good afternoon
can you hear me we can
very good thank you
um
i did a written testimony i can read
[Laughter]
we're all excellent readers
okay yeah very good
well if you just want to
explain in your own words would be
helpful to us
okay
well this um
proposed change would
buy time
for
both the top tax collectors many of whom
are also town clerks
and
overwhelmed
with duties
and um
make sure that
the biggest problem if these letters
don't get postmarked on time
then the town loses their ability
to go forward with further collection of
the unpaid
tax levy
the property cannot go to deed if the
letters did not get mailed out in time
two years before that
so that's the bottom line
that concludes
okay
other questions for ms sanders
yes
ms d lorenzo
representative lorenzo
thank you for taking my question
um and thank you
mr chair
good afternoon miss sanders um
so this bill it seems to be really
simple do you have a supporter for your
town clerks and tax collectors on this
bill
i have probably spoken to 50 or 60
town clerks and tax collectors and its
unanimous support
well thank you
i just want to remark that this seems to
be new market day in judiciary because
miss sanders lives in new market and we
have um
this becky benvenuti in the wings who
works at mna
nhma
and she is used to be a pneumatic town
clerk so
thank you
are there any other questions for miss
sanders
sing none thank you for your testimony
my pleasure thank you for listening
appreciate it
can you hear me now
we can yes thank you mr chairman and
good afternoon committee members i will
not also uh take up your time by going
through the testimony which i did submit
to you in an email
about a half hour ago
but i nhma is in support of this bill um
perfecting
the inherent tax lien which exists on
all properties um
april first of every year to ensure that
municipalities interest as and position
as a secured first priority lien holder
is of course very important and as jane
said if this process
um statutory process is not followed
precisely and correctly or if a deadline
is missed then the municipality loses
its ability to acquire a valid tax deed
for the properties
two years later if there are any
unredeemed
taxes remaining
so
again we respectfully urge the committee
to vote in support of hb 126. thank you
thank you
are there any questions for ms benvenuti
yes
uh
representative macbeth thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um
so i understand that this um
provides some flexibility for the town
clerks
um and tax collectors to provide notice
um to the citizen
is there a companion piece of
law that we need to
also um push the 60 days that the
citizens themselves that like maybe that
the um you know the the fees or interest
on this lien or whatever or or their
taxes do doesn't start you know that
they also have that extra
month or
15 days to to um you know start when the
fees start that they wouldn't start
until notice
thank you for that question that's
actually a really great great question
um so the way the statute works is the
tax collectors are required to provide
30 days certified return receipt notice
to the property owners
that's what starts the entire process
and and prior to that they have to
provide delinquency notices
after the second or the final tax uh
bill is issued so the final tax bill
gets issued a delinquency notice is
required to be sent to all property tax
payers that still have remaining taxes
due
and then um in preparation for
perfecting the tax lien the certified
return receipt lien notice is required
to be sent to the property owners 30
days in advance of executing the tax
lien
following the execution of the tax lien
that's where the 45 days comes in so
once the tax lien is executed that
search must begin and and the there's a
45 day period
to conduct that search get the notices
ready and then the mortgages are noticed
following that being successfully
completed
thank you for
that thank you
you're welcome
are there any other questions for ms
benvenuti
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today you're very welcome thank you for
your time
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
that being the case i'll close the
hearing on house bill 126
i note that there were
25 people who signed up in advance and
supported the bill and no one in
opposition
mr chair would it be in order to have an
executive session on this bill right now
is there anyone on the committee who
would object
to
having an executive session on this bill
i don't see anyone who would object
then
i was
looking at procedures that i might be
familiar with the town in terms of
taking a roll call to go into executive
session but i understand that that isn't
necessary to do so
and that we can because we have noticed
it
go into executive session by declaration
and so i'm going to indicate that we
are
now in executive session
and
i will call upon representative
alexander if he would like to make a
motion
um thank you mr chair i move um hb 126
otp
okay representative alexander has moved
the
house bill 126 the
odd to pass and and representative rice
has seconded that motion
is there any discussion
um mr chair i just think this is a
straightforward bill and i think we
heard reasons why um it just gives more
flexibility to the towns and i think we
are you ready to vote
appears we are
so
i know we're not
okay
so
take take two minutes here i get to
figure out okay a second in the motion
represent rice
representative rice who's my file right
here
oh for goodness sakes and we we need to
uh
in order to take that vote we need to be
able to see everyone so representative
silvia could you
uh-huh did i do that yet no i thought
uh what happened here is the principles
okay we got that
we always like to catch the clerk by
surprise
uh
i will figure it out
mr chairman
yes
while the clerk is getting things in
order
is it possible for the clerk to be given
um
the old-fashioned paper
roll call sheets
so that he could fill that out easily
and then subsequently
send it along to go into the
so let me answer that
am i on so yes i i don't really think
that's necessary what's necessary is for
me to correct this file or
and help it's to know ahead of time so
i've already made
like for today i made files for the
public hearing and i made files for the
executive session but i did not make
roll call sheets
right and it still takes
a little bit of time to manipulate the
files right so
uh
we're doing a lot better than we did the
other day and this one will go
not as well probably about the same as
what
the attendance did which wasn't all that
good but
i would just like to add that observing
a number of other committees in the last
10 days
i would say that we are
at the top
appropriate behavior appropriate
procedure
and that is a tribute to the clerk and
to the chair
thank you
thank you madam chair
where is it's up here in malaya
oh never mind i'll fix that later all
right so the motion is out to pass on
housing am i on
yep yes you are oh good
so the motion is
okay fine i know i can't minimize the
window
the motion is ought to pass on house
bill 126.
if you're in favor of that motion you
say well something in that along that
line if you're opposed you'll say
something along a different line
uh representative mclean
yes
or you're
the clerk votes yes
representative alexander yes
representative rice
yes
representative silber yes
representative greene
yes
representative kelly
representative tosh
yes
representative trotter here
yes representative how do you actually
say your name
claudia
thank you
representative smith yes
representative oregon
yes
representative di lorenzo yes
representative
got it
thank you
representative kenny
yes
representative langley yes
where am i what's my space
seventeen
oh that one's right representative
mcbeath
yes thank you
representative page
yes
representative simpson
mr chairman
now that is that is one that we could
put on the consent calendar i don't know
representative alexander to put it on
the consent calendar and seconded by
whom
i'll second it
seconded by representative chase do i
have to put this has to want you some
voice
do we have to vote on this again after
another roll call for this
um
mr chair i don't think so i think you
could have said
if there is no objection
we can put this on the consent calendar
and then
that would fulfill our um
obligations
any one person objects it doesn't go on
consent okay
well no
before before you regard that now that
wouldn't be right you can put it on
consent with more than one
more than just a couple but you'd have
to do a roll call to make that decision
that is true but if there is no
objection agreed
then there is no need for the roll call
i believe
so that's why the chair would say um
you know if it is no objection this will
go on
the consent calendar and that leaves the
rest of us free to say no no no no
but i haven't heard any objections
without objection
house bill 126 will be placed on the
consent calendar
now is your time to object if you wanted
hearing none
hearing none it will be placed
on the consent calendar
um mr chair just a uh
procedural question
um i still i would have to write a
committee report on this correct yes
where would i submit that
yes you will have to do a committee
report
and uh
and
yes
you send it to the chat i think you
would send it to the chair as we did
before because the chair
would have to um agree
with what you say and then the chair can
send it to the appropriate staff people
right and i i can't do what
representative smith did last year and
that say you you have to submit it
before you leave the room
[Laughter]
you can too if you just stay you could
try we're gonna close the room
um
but yes uh
and i guess if you could get that to me
by the end of the week that would be
great
i will do that thank you mr chair
is there a specific form that we need to
do to use
and
if so
where is that available
or the committee reports
i don't know if she's on the call
oh yes i do see
so here
when when i would send in a committee
report
um because you know i didn't have it
done by the end of the day you just you
just have to send it in and and i think
the committee assistant can and um do
the rest you just kind of put on it you
know
otp and and all that but there's no
specific form
but
jen can tell us
where to send and i don't think we have
the um
the committee assistance that we have
we usually have right but he should he
should know who our committee assistant
is i mean i know who mine is for
children and family right so
yeah it's rebecca
but if you send a report to me i'll
i'll look it over and then i'll get it
okay is there any uh uh representative
or representative macbeth
um
is there anything else we
anything else we want to address during
mr chairman yep
would it be
possible to discuss um 395 about the
3.95 that was the home share bill
correct
yep
i just really felt that um this bill
needed a lot of work i i like the
concept of it and whatnot but i i think
that it needs some more work so i'd like
it if we could retain it and work on it
uh do you want to make that emotion i
certainly do
are we still are we still in executive
session we are our chair
we are
now you're killing me
and
uh is there a uh is there a second to
the motion first of all
representative lorenzo has seconded it
and
is that what bill was that 395 3.95
in discussion
so
well i mean like i said
there i i think this this bill needs
kind of a lot of work so i'd like to see
if we can
um
work on it because i i i understand the
need of the north country needing this
but um
i think that we we need to work on it a
little more
okay
uh representative sylvia
uh yes i think this bill has a little
bit more than a little work to do on it
and i think it would be better to itl
and if it's retained i will
i understand
and
uh representative langley
did you have your hand up um yes i did
thank you mr chair
um i i would agree um with
representatives rice's comments i think
the bill needs more clarity and
certainly um
more specific definitions i thought it
was really vague although i love the
concept and i think it has lots of
potential i think the cl the lack of
clarity would cause lots of problems
eventually particularly for other
regions if they tried to implement it
it um
you know i just said i i thought that
uh it it
it's a concept that has value but
i think the questions that were raised
as to whether it was in the appropriate
statute
and the lack of definition
really
made it something i think is going to
require some work
other comments
yeah uh representative horrigan
um i have a procedural question and uh
if we
retain it does that prevent um
the sponsors or some other alternative
sponsors from
um putting together a build during the
next filing period this fall and um
and or do they or just retain bill the
only vehicle they would have in the
i believe as long as we don't itl it
representative green
what stuck on my mind was the testimony
of one of the folks saying that
if the committee wants to define home
share i'm not opposed to it that to me
you know that
was enough for me to
any other
thank you um
in some respects i agree with
representative sylvia it's this bill
require is going to require a lot more
than tinkering around the edges and some
definitional changes
uh it seemed to me that the premise of
the bill
was that
some
some organization
was going to um
supervise monitor and otherwise
filter
the process
none of that's in the bill and so i
think if the bill is going to be
retained
uh it's going to take uh massive surgery
okay
any other comments
representative lorenzo thank you mr
clear i agree with what representative
birch just said that the bill does need
a lot of work and i think one of my main
concerns is around life safety issues
and
because we're talking about vulnerable
individuals um
in a home who could be taken advantage
of i also worry about fire code building
codes um emergency situations
so
and i hate to add and add more
regulations but um
i think that lives could be at stake
here if this isn't isn't done correctly
can i just ask representative lorenzo
does that mean you support the motion or
support would support a motion to
i would support emotion to retain it
are you ready
yes representative smith uh thank you
very much um
if one has prejudices and biases
it's
important to always
communicate those so people know that
and i'm not necessarily referring to
this bill but i'm referring to the ease
with which we might agree to retain
bills
um
if a bill needs an incredible amount of
work
it is not really the committee's
responsibility
and
but it becomes the committee's
responsibility if we retain and every
bill
that you vote to retain means you are
going to have to spend time in the
summer and the fall
we're not
we're not using
retention in a way that it should be
used so i would just urge people
as they vote
to be sure
that it is a bill that they believe
is worth
improving and working on and they are
willing to put the time in
um just putting off
a decision
is not a good reason
if the motion stands to
retain i would vote to retain the bill
but i just wanted to um
make that point
the worst thing
that could happen to us as a committee
is to suddenly find that we have a very
long list of bills that have to be
worked on during the summer and fall
well i guess that's the question i'd ask
and uh you know
representative sylvia sort of mentioned
it and said
i really don't want to work on this i
don't want to be put onto a committee is
there anybody
on our committee who wants to be put on
and and and maybe that's the answer to
the question you know representative
langley did you have your hand i would
i will yes yes i would
okay
i think it's worthy of it i i you know i
mean we may not
come out with with something we can we
can do we may find that it's too
difficult but i think it deserves more
than a half hours worth of time in our
committee today
to come by that this is a problem
they're having in the north country and
i think we should at least try to
address it
thank you
uh
representative wilper did you have a
comment a question well i do because um
i agree with pretty much everything that
has been said thus far
so i think i personally think this is an
excellent idea and it's something that's
needed not just in the north country
but across our state
so
it's worthy of a lot of work
but i
am don't want to spend
so first of all i have no the more i
heard today the more work i think it
needs
we don't know where it wants to go in
the statutes we don't even know who the
the real stakeholders are the whole idea
of agreeing on some kind of an
organization or whatever some kind of an
administrative portion of this
it needs to be done
but if
that work can get done and the new bill
introduced next year well
they act people actually think they can
get it done
between now and
because we have to report this back for
if we i don't know
i don't i think it's too much for us to
do as a retained bill
i think uh
thank you mr chair i was um just
thinking about that all the housing
issues that we're hearing about and that
we know we have around the state and
there aren't there aren't going to be a
lot of simple fixes i think
for that situation across the state so i
think that's why i'm willing to invest
some time in just to see if this is a
possible um one possible solution
there
representative silver
uh yes uh
i think that the role
for revising this to get it into
acceptable form
rightfully belongs to the sponsors not
to the committee
so my view is that i would vote against
retaining the bill and i would vote itl
thank you
and
uh
representative horrigan
um yes
first of all as for the itl
as for the itl if if we
if if we go with the itl and if the full
house agrees with it then um the
sponsors would not be able to introduce
a bill in the house uh your next filing
period unless it uh less was tabled on
the floor but that's uh that's beyond
the purview of this committee um
even though we have the speaker pro tem
sitting on the committee but that's a
separate role that she has so that you
know if we retain the bill some of the
sponsors could come in the process we
probably will be retaining a lot more
bills um
this year probably every committee will
be although um
retaining this one today may be
premature and uh and and unnecessary
since we've seen
we seem to have
agreed this bill is like pretty far from
anything that we can actually pass so
but
um
that's just uh
i i'm i'm not actually not 100 decided
on what i want to do with it i don't
really don't feel comfortable retaining
this
retaining this one but i don't really
representative rice
thank you so i i just kind of have a
question and i should probably know the
answer to this but i don't because i i
almost feel like this bill is
would be better as two separate bills
so
um
if we idled it
if they brought back two separate bills
in the
fall would they be able to do that
i just they could they do that
representative smith
oh sorry representative gordon
that's okay
sorry
i can't i can't hear representative
representative gordon knows that i
worship at his
chairman's feet so
he wouldn't take offense
of you asking me a question
couldn't
i think that's fair to say
in no way would i want to be chair today
so
so but are you going to answer them
so kim yeah i think you're right this
was two bills last year
and they bring of course that was a
different session
right right but so but right so that's
that's my question is if we itl this
could the sponsors then divide this into
two and bring each bill back separately
for the next
session
do you know what i mean for the the next
i do
time around
and when i get it
if they itl if we itl the bill
they cannot bring the same bill back for
the second year of the session
but they could bring back
different bills on the same
subject general
ti in the same church but not the same
pew
so i think then perhaps i would like to
withdraw my motion
about you would you would draw your
second
so that means uh
motion having been withdrawn and the
second having been withdrawn we're back
to go do you want to act on the bill at
all i guess is the question i'm going to
move itl
second
who was that that seconded silver
representative silver seconded the
motion
moved by representative rice
don't see any
representative simpson
can i ask a clarifying another
clarifying question um
if it's all right
i was wondering if they bring the either
this please
thank you if they bring this bill back
as one bill or two bills if they bring
it under um as was suggested by someone
i think that they bring it under a
different statute
does that count as a different bill like
they do all the work and it comes under
a different statute that might also
count as a different
uh attempt right
you know frankly
the question is who's going to object to
it
if they bring it back
and
and frankly given the discussion we've
had here today i'm not sure that anybody
any other discussion
are you ready to vote
no
okay the motion
uh the motion we have is to make
a
house bill 395 fn inexpedient to
legislate
and the clerk can call the rule
the clerk can call the roll inexpedience
and legislate on house bill 395
representative mclean
yes
representative sylvia yes
representative walper yes
representative alexander
no
oh now i gotta do i'm gonna go over the
uh representative where am i at
alexander rice
oh because i put three in joe's
one two oh actually one two wait a
minute what's going on here i have to
okay three one two three you're number
four
representative silver yes
representative green
yes
representative kelly
where'd that go
kelly
seven
yes
yes no
uh that's a fair question
would i do
9.
okay representative smith
yes
representative birch
representative burns representative
horrigan
i'm gonna go don't
don't
representative diorenzo yes
representative kenny
yes
representative langley yes
representative mcbeth had to go to
commerce
representative page
yes
representative simpson
no
that would be
three
mr chairman
yes
that would be
17 to three
yes
and one extension
yeah
what did i do maybe we just put not
voting in there
and representative rice will be writing
the committee report
we
mr chair yes i will
i forgot about that part
yeah
mr chair
yes
um following up on representative rice's
enthusiastic acceptance of having to
write the report
i wonder if she could be
clear in the report
um
that the committee thought
many of the um
issues in the bill
were important and deserved
further
investigation but that the bill itself
was not ready
right now for us to act on i think
that it will be important for the since
that's true
i think it would be important to reflect
that in the blurb
no you're not supposed to call it a
blurb anymore what are you supposed to
call it now report report report report
thank you
um
i think it would be helpful to them as
they go about drafting another version
so it's just a suggestion
thank you
is there anybody who wants to write a
uh mr chair i agree with representative
smith and i think we just have different
ways of getting the same solution we all
understand it's a um it's a problem it
should be a priority we just think it
should i thought it should happen um
this year not next year so um i'm not
writing a report
thank you
well seeing no one who wishes to write a
minority report then we will report it
out
as inexpedient to legislate and
representative rice rice will write the
uh
and write the committee report
uh well we have some people who
object
object to having it on the consent
gallery
if that's the case then without a i'm
not sure i can do it without objection i
guess we'd have to vote if we have
yeah you'd have to do without objection
yeah and as long as they don't object
you can go ahead and have it on the on
the consent calendar as long as the
three that voted against it or even
someone that did as long as they
are okay with it going on consent
okay
then without objection i'll
uh
it will uh the
house bill 395 fm will be placed on our
recommendation will be placed on the
so done
okay we need to move on house bill 287
relative to remote notarization uh we're
out of executive session excuse me
and we're now moving on to our next
hearing which is on house bill 287
relative to remote
notarization
the primary sponsor of that bill was
and i don't know if he is available
under his circumstances to participate
today
um
mr chair if nobody is able to um
introduce that i can introduce it on his
behalf and maybe we can recess it or i
don't know what you want to do with that
that would be fine uh if you wouldn't
okay uh
mr chair um for the record my name is
representative alexander i represent the
town of goffstown hillsborough district
six um i am here to introduce hb
um 287 relative to remote notarization
um thank you to the committee for having
me
thank you for your brief testimony
uh
with regard to
there's only
uh one person who was actually signed up
to testify that's tom
prasal
from the mortgage bankers and mr prasal
yes i was actually under the impression
this was the number to call for snow
removal services from representative
alexander
[Laughter]
in all seriousness though uh good
afternoon chairman gordon members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
tom prasall from demers and praisaw and
i'm here today representing the mortgage
bankers and brokers association of new
hampshire
uh you may have noticed that i noted my
position as neutral however the mortgage
bankers and brokers association fully
support the intent of the legislation
to provide a little background in 2020
the mortgage bankers and brokers asked
senator kavanaugh to introduce
legislation to establish a commission to
study the implementation
of remote online notarization in new
hampshire
as 22 states have begun to modify their
notary laws to move in this direction we
felt the time was right for new
hampshire to explore joining them
well that legislation did pass the
senate unanimously
due to covid
the bill wasn't unable to be heard in
the house and therefore
was laid on the table and didn't pass
and i think we can all agree that
the timing couldn't have been worse
because we really needed remote online
notarization during this crisis
governor sununu did issue an executive
order number 11 to allow for a form of
remote online notarization
which has been helpful to businesses and
residents during these challenging times
governor sununu has indicated some of
his priorities for the session would be
addressing executive orders that could
be put into statute
as a result a group of stakeholders who
otherwise would have been on the
commission had met over the summer and
fall to draft a more robust remote
online notarization law with the input
of all the stakeholders involved that
language was provided to senator
cavanaugh to be introduced in the senate
where it has currently been placed into
an omnibus bill that has yet to be
scheduled and the language is not yet
available
i will note that representative
danielson is was a co-sponsor of the lsr
from senator kavanaugh and senator
carson will be this prime sponsor of the
house bill 287 is
not an early bill and so my
request is that the committee hold this
bill until such time as the senate has
acted on the version that the
stakeholders agreed to
and hopefully that will make its way
over to you um if that's not the case
then my request would be to retain the
bill or i can provide the language when
it's available from the office of
legislative services
and provide that to you to be brought
forward as an amendment
i did want to note that the stakeholders
who did participate in the drafting of
the senate language were the new
hampshire bankers association the new
hampshire credit union league the new
hampshire realtors the registers of
deeds several title companies as well as
the secretary of state offered their
input
i thought it may be helpful to provide
the committee with some background on
what's happening relative to remote
online notarization
in new hampshire
however carol willoughby from first
american title
she was very instrumental in helping to
draft the language as she has worked on
this legislation in other states
and i don't believe she has signed up to
speak however she is available in the
zoom waiting room if anyone has any
technical questions or questions on
remote notarization i would uh defer to
her given her expertise and knowledge in
yeah any questions for mr praise song
yes
representative silber
the question i have is since i
formerly lived and practiced law in
florida for many years before i was able
to escape
florida has a similar statute but they
also have a statutory short form of
acknowledgement that specifically
indicates whether the notarization is
taking place in person or remotely is
there any plan to have a companion
proposal to adopt something like that
for new hampshire
thank you representative i certainly
appreciate the question again you know i
think you know carol willoughby would
certainly be someone that she may be
more familiar with the florida law that
you're referencing and may be able to
thank you mr chair thank you mr pricelow
for taking my question first of all if
what you presented is in written form
can you submit that
so that we can have make reference to it
when we think about the bill
and absolutely
thank you that's appreciated
um
stepping back a bit
uh
what in this day and age
in the 21st century what's the value
of notarization in the first place
uh in the olden days
somebody came in and you knew who the
person was and you could say yeah that
was john smith who came in and signed
that document and i can testify to that
later
um we're moving more and more remote
from that concept
is there a reason to do notarization
anymore
i you know that's a great question and i
it's a very
broad idea and concept that i don't know
if i'm prepared to speak to the overall
benefits or downsides to notarizations
in general um however we felt that you
know given many states are moving into a
more modern age of moving to a remote
notarization we would at least take that
step first
thank you
and
other questions for mr prasal yes
yes
representative representative macbeth
i i would comment to and to um
i think that um there are a lot more
reasons um that we would be
uh
not just notarizing but a testing to
someone's it's not just identifying a
person it's a testing to documents it's
attesting to the oath of someone the you
know so there are broad reasons for
um notorious acts and i think that this
bill covers a lot more than just
identifying yeah it's tom smith so um i
appreciate the proponents of the bill
bringing it forward
and mr chairman if i may i did receive a
note from uh carol who's on the call
that she said she could speak to
representative silber's question if uh
if that's something you wish to do we
would i see her hand up and we will be
calling on her
great
well thank you all for taking the time
any other questions from
for mr praise hall
sing none thank you for your testimony
and we do have carol willoughby who
good afternoon can you hear me okay
we can you're a little low you could
speak up
all right i'll do my best how's that
okay
thank you
gordon and members of the committee for
um asking me to comment on this question
on both of them i'll take
representatives um silver's question
first
yes the new hampshire draft legislation
that the stakeholders have put forward
which um
mr prasad has discussed
does account for the notion of someone
who lives out of state or is out of
country so
uh individuals who are living in other
parts of the world even you know
depending on the law of that
jurisdiction so yes
even though you're
saved from florida
um we can we could use that law to work
with you remotely in that respect
and to
speak representative
question um i concur
with represent representative mcphee in
that there is um
a very broad
uh role of the note of the notary
they're both gonna confirm the person's
identity
they have an important role in assessing
capacity to undertake the
outcome that they are taking
they have
a broad and responsibility to certify
that the signers acknowledgement
is given freely and voluntarily
um and and then alternatively
um as you can probably tell i'm from the
title's insurance industry and the
material act underlies really the
um
the
the um our land records you know of the
the uh ability for our land records to
stand as they are
trusted
and um to not be overturned
the proposed legislation has a lot of
protections in it
what they're happy to tell you about if
you're interested
okay
are there questions questions for ms
willoughby
i don't see any
thank you for your testimony today uh
mr chairman yeah
could i who who is carol will be is she
representing anybody or what
normally you put down who people
represent and whether they support or
oppose and i don't have that information
sure my name is carol willoughby
i am a regional underwriting director
for first american title insurance
i'm a resident here of the state
and a licensed attorney and i worked
with the stakeholder group through the
mortgage bankers and brokers association
who has put forward the proposed bill
did you get that
representative
uh close enough okay she she works for
american title
sure
oh american title i just started i put
down she was a title insurance
underwriter and supports the bill that's
the key parts that i need for this first
american title
first american
whatever
okay
and
are there any other questions that
people have for ms willoughby
again
thank you again for your testimony
uh i don't there were
four people who registered in support of
the bill
no one
registered in opposition to the bill
and i don't have anybody else who's
is there um
are there any attendees who wish to
speak
don't see any
so i'll close the hearing
and i completely misjudged the length of
is there anything else that you might
consider executing today or would you
like to take a break for a half an hour
i can use a break
why don't we
plan to read why don't we plan to recess
and reconvene
at three o'clock for our last hearing on
cacr10
thank you
what are you calling sweetheart
my wife is that okay oh but you're
this
and sharon how do you think we're doing
i think we're going to do well um
got a nice letter from um
our friend at new hampshire municipal
association um
yeah i mean i sent him back a thank you
note for that
i couldn't get over it because he's he's
always been sort of like you know
quickly above the bill yeah yeah
so
the hra had a little fight over that the
other night oh really
i'm going to be honest i don't think we
can be discussing this because it hasn't
been
publicly noticed thank you
sorry
i guess you're right there's a lot of
people here
i don't yeah there's too many people
i'll go back to playing with my files
well for one minute i guess not
okay it being three o'clock i'll call
the
we have one more hearing schedule for
this afternoon that's cacr10
with regard to the powers of the
legislature the bill provides that the
legislature may overturn any decision of
a state court concerning interpretation
of a state law
the primary sponsor is representative
lewicki
and
is
representative lewicki available to
testify
i do not see him in the list of
attendees
we have a we have a call-in user mr
chair um
is that
representative of the wiki
it very well could be because he doesn't
have like the whole computer thing
okay
representative of wiki if that's you
you need to
which is stars
you are
yep am i
yes you are you're
unmuted now
okay
all right thank you
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee i'm john lewicki i
represent hillsborough district 26.
thank you for the opportunity to
over the past hundred or so years there
has been a revolution in the state and
federation it hasn't been the sort of
revolution that involves pitchforks and
guns it's more like a revolution of
boiled frogs
when our constitutions were enacted in
1784 and 1789 we changed the world by
creating constitutional republics
responsible to the people of the states
however we kept one relic of the british
government the legal system
since at the time it was perceived to be
fair and honest there seemed to be
little reason to change
the fatal flaw in our constitution is
that we allowed the courts to overturn
constitution and statute by setting
precedence
as a result our constitution is now
littered with amendments overturning
wrong precedents
here in the legislature we frequently
see bills the only purpose of which is
to restore a previous plainly written
statute
when the courts found that they could
make law by setting precedence we
started down a slippery slope
in many cases the courts were encouraged
by parties who were unable to get what
they wanted from elected government
presently it has become common for
people to make end runs around elected
government by persuading the courts to
become activists for them
it is appropriate in case like this to
return to the philosophers who
established our constitutional
government
thomas paine and the rights of man
foresaw that a government by president
would devolve to what we have today
the complete quotations and testimony i
emailed to the committee
there is a natural tendency for
institutions and the people in them to
take on power beyond those granted to
them by the people
when that occurs it's always at the
expense of the people's freedom
we're here today to talk about a
provision that addresses the
relationship between statutory law and
precedence established by courts
a for instance may be better than
another form of explanation a few years
ago we passed a statute to make alimony
uniform throughout the state
previously independent of the discretion
of the courts presently a lower court
might diverge from the statute
one of the involved parties might then
appeal to the state supreme court
if the supreme court fails to act the
lower court has then set a precedent
which effectively replaces the statute
a party affected by the president has no
further ability to appeal
this cacr if approved by the people
would allow appeal of a precedent
concerning a statute to be appealed to
the general court
the general court by simple majority of
both houses could effectively remain the
decision back to the courts in effect
saying you got it wrong the statute
means what it says
this would be a much better solution
than to essentially reiterate the law in
a new statute which would then have to
be signed by the governor
so this since this would only be a
reaffirmation of an existing statute
there's no reason for the government to
be involved
the basic principle behind this is the
laws belong to the legislature they
don't belong to the courts
this cacr would restore out to our state
the concept that the people should
govern themselves through their
constitutional elected government it
would end government by appointed courts
and statutory matters
there's an inherent conflict between
self-government and law by precedent
that the fatal flaw which needs to be
addressed in the people's constitution
ruled by precedent means the dead may
ruin the living
all of us here whether we call ourselves
a republic or a democracy and regardless
of what party labor we wear believe in
government of the people by the people's
represented elected representatives
i encourage you to send the cacr to the
full legislature with a recommendation
of ought to pass
that's all i have thank you
thank you for your testimony and are
there questions for
i don't see any questions
and again thank you for your testimony
today
i don't have anyone else who signed up
to testify today i guess uh john tobin
perhaps us
wishes to testify
thank you mr chairman
um
you mr chairman can you hear me now we
can
okay i will be brief um and i sent you a
few minutes ago a written version of my
testimony um by email
um
thank you for the opportunity to speak
about this thank you for your service to
our state in the middle of a pandemic
and today in the middle of a snowstorm
i'm a retired lawyer and i'm a retired
court
volunteer mediator and i'm
speaking in opposition to
um this proposed amendment to the
constitution today um and
uh i will try to be as brief as i can um
you have had a long day and i realize
that um our this constitutional movement
would disrupt
um and damage the the system of checks
and balances and separation of powers
that
is the core framework of both our state
and our federal constitutions
and the other thing it would do
is that it would turn you all the
legislature into an appeals court um
anyone who was unhappy with a decision
in their divorce case their business
dispute their boundary dispute could
hire a lobbyist and come to the
legislature and say i want to i want to
get the legislature to overturn this
court decision i don't like um
there's
in this amendment as it's proposed
there's no limit on that so essentially
this amendment would turn you all into
the ultra appeals court um
and that would mean
in in practicality that people who
had enough money to hire a lobbyist and
pursue their case in the legislature
after they've lost it in the court
system
might be able to do that it would be one
more barrier for ordinary people
who
have participated in an individual case
in the court system
um and then there's been a decision that
both parties have to live with um in our
in our system
you the legislature create policy you
set the rules for daily life in our
in our state you also have complex
decisions to make about budgets
you are not set up to
adjudicate individual disputes between
individuals and corporations and state
agencies that's what the judiciary does
and it's inevitable that the three
branches of government have tension from
time to time you are separate you are
independent but your roles overlap and
part of the beauty of our system is that
creative tension
but this
this proposal would obliterate
that creative tension it would
essentially usurp the role of the courts
and put you in the legislature in the
role of a super appeals court it doesn't
make sense from a legislative point of
view doesn't make sense in terms of
fairness and finality in the legal
system
and you have plenty of other things to
do and you also have remedies if you're
unhappy with it with how a statute has
been interpreted you can amend the
statute you can repeal the statute
um so
you you can do what you need to do in
your policy-making way
to deal with statutes that you don't
think are
interpreted correctly
but you certainly don't want to turn
yourself into an appeals court
representative rice did you have a
question
yes thank you
thank you for your testimony and thanks
for taking my question
so um i guess my question is because i
um sit on children and family law also
and i hear a lot
about judicial discretion and how
they're not following policy
but they're using their judicial
discretion and i i almost feel like um
this cacr is in an attempt to
sway that from happening
um what is your take on judicial
discretion
well one of the things about that is
is a limitation of what you can do um is
that
you can't possibly and anticipate when
you're writing laws every particular
fact situation
that may arose in a dispute between two
parties you can create a for instance a
very lengthy law on alimony and child
support but you can't necessarily
anticipate
every single potential way that those
issues are going to arise
so you set out the rules and then
somebody has to interpret those rules as
best they can
based on the facts in front of them and
so
judges do not have discretion to ignore
the law what they have is the ability to
fill in the gaps
when
something isn't crystal clear from the
law um
and
that doesn't happen all that often the
you know in most areas what the statute
says is pretty clear and people
understand it
it's only in the unusual circumstances
where there's some ambiguity or doubt
and that's a perfect that's another
perfect opportunity for you all as
policy makers to resolve that issue by
further
writing the law to remove that ambiguity
um
so some discretion and ambiguity is
inevitable when
judges are hearing
cases about individual facts and
individual stories and circumstances
but you always have the ability to
change the law as these things arise to
fix it and to make it closer to
what you all think the best policy
you all said
right yes thank you representative
oregon
you're muted representative oregon
oh you're not missing much but thank you
very much mr chair thank you very much
mr tobin um
this uh
the thing with this bill is as i read it
says any decision of a state court so we
wouldn't if this cacr be being part of
the constitution it sounds like we
wouldn't even have to wait for the
supreme court to weigh in we could
um we could jump in even before the
supreme court
yes that's what it usually does which is
pretty much the same thing given to the
legislature
yes that's another way that this would
disrupt the legal system um
it would really be
uh
an end run around the legal system um
and it could happen at any time and
there's no
there's no um
filter either there's nothing to say
there's nothing to help you
screen cases that are without merit or
screen cases that really involve
fact disputes that
that you don't have the ability to rule
on
what you are there for is to talk about
policy but not to be fact-finders and
hear testimony and decide who's telling
the truth you all are policy makers
and this this amendment would put you
uh it smack into the business of
adjudicating facts and deciding who's
telling the truth um
it would really you become
very much full-time judges and again
without any structure
without any of any process of how you
fit into the legal system
any other questions for mr tobin
yes
representative silber
uh thank you mr chair thank you mr tobin
for taking my question sure
am i correct in that there are two types
of decisions that this seems to address
in just that one sentence their
decisions of a court interpreting
statutes
and their decisions of the core of a
court interpreting the state
constitution
those there are some
court cases that interpret both but by
far by far
the much more frequent one is is courts
interpreting a statute okay follow-up
may i follow up sure the follow-up is
then don't we already in the general
court if we're not happy with an
interpretation by a of a statute by the
court
don't we already have the the power in
the general court to adopt a new statute
that overturns that decision absolutely
you can rewrite the statute and it
happens all the time
final question final follow-up
if
if we're if we're not happy with an
interpretation of the state constitution
by the supreme court
who
in our system is supposed to say what
the constitution means if not the state
supreme court
under our system
the supreme court is the final
interpreter of the constitution and
that's new hampshire's system and in the
federal system but you all have the
ability to initiate an amendment to a
constitution if you don't like a ruling
any other questions
comments
seeing none
and i don't see anyone else with their
hand raise who wants to speak is there
any
one who's in attendance who does want to
speak
seeing none uh i would note that on the
list of people who
expressed an opinion there were
27 people who expressed an opinion in
opposition
and
one who
submitted an opinion and support
and with that i'll close the hearing on
cacr10
and is there any other business before
if not
then we will
thank you mr share would it be
appropriate to accept this bill today
um
if there's
if no one objects to that we would go
into executive session
okay
thank you
would you like to would you like to do
that
yes i would
does anybody have an objection to go
into executive session to address this
bill
i see no objection so i will indicate
that the committee is now
in executive session
and representative lorenzo
as a follow-up to that do you want to
make a motion
yes i'd like to make a motion of
an expedient to legislate
is there a second to that second second
uh representative horgan i see your is
that your hand up did you want to speak
oh sure yes well my first point is um
any cacr
even though i actually have my name and
a co-sponsor of one which is not in your
art committee but
doing naca cr right now is
extremely
premature partially uh partially
factored like we're not operating 100
uh efficiency because of the pandemic
and all the new things we're doing but
also like the voters cannot vote on this
until november 20
2022 so certainly if we wanted to pass
this or if we wanted to pass with
changes there'd be really no points in
uh
doing that sending to the floor now we
would
don't lose anything by waiting till next
year but this particular one it's a uh
it's a uh poorly thought out idea and
it's a basically a bad idea i i was uh
revenue birch would probably tease me
for reading in person but i would
remember the petitions and rejects
committee
back in 2011 to 2012 would try to do
this and
aside from the fact that
constitutionally we weren't allowed to
overturn
state courts um
a house committee just really doesn't
have the resources that a that a court
does you know they like the uh supreme
court usually does what they return to
the legislature so there's only
five justices they've got a whole uh
they've got a fairly large staff of
professionals who do nothing but uh you
know
help them research the interpretation of
state statutes in the constitution
whereas like the
committee on fictitious and redress had
basically
no staff at all so it was kind of
haphazard i mean probably if this did
pass we would probably put more of a
structure in place for dealing with
these resolutions when we get them but
it was a you know we were
might be a little bit better on the
senate side where you know they have
desks and they have you know
staff people assigned to each senator
but for us
for the 400 of us it would be i think
it'd be pretty much
possible for us to come to an informed
decision on
the types of issues that the state
supreme court deals with when they're
feeling things or that they're better i
suppose we could even get some things
that would otherwise go to the federal
appeals courts i just think uh
i just think this is a
totally totally impractical like totally
impractical idea that is necessary given
the way we're
this institution the house is structured
right now would be really very very
difficult for us to reinvent ourselves
in a way
that would we would be able to deal with
these issues effectively even if we had
the constitutional power to do so on the
unit was a good idea to give us a
constitutional power and that's
certainly
one of the main reasons why it's a bad
idea they give us a constitutional power
of course is because
this would be by simple majority and the
majority flips back and forth from party
to party and there's you know the
parties has its own you know
uh it
has his own uh groups within their
within the party so like this would uh
this would like overturn a lot of
decisions that right now are
you know starry to stysis established
law we hear a lot about the importance
of you know at least accepting
certain decisions
as established law even if we're not
necessarily
crazy about them so this would this
would politicize you know every issue
and then a lot of these things would
just keep changing every every few years
as the you know the makeup of the
legislature changed so uh
i gave about a million reasons why this
is a bad idea we probably only needed
one but that's uh
anyway that that's what i have to say
about this so thank you
and representing sylvia
thank you mr chairman um i wouldn't be
so dismissive of this idea
while i
uh
perfect i think there's certainly merit
to discussing
such an issue um
as far as the supreme court being the
ultimate authority i disagree i think
the people of the state are the ultimate
authority
um and certainly the legislature
if they see bad decisions representative
rice
uh
i don't see representatives so sylvia
but he was still talking
there he is
i'm here did i go away or was it the
chairman that went away i don't know
i'm not sure but representative sylvia
was still talking i'm sorry
it's all right
so i was saying that uh i believe it's
the the people that have the ultimate
authority in the state
furthermore bad decisions uh made by the
court we also have uh
impeachment possibilities for a
bad
judge or perhaps a whole court if
they're terribly wrong
i don't think this is a horrible idea
i think that we also have the ability to
um
consider things uh like i think
claremont uh being a great example of
bad decisions
that just uh keep echoing throughout the
state and our laws
perhaps you know what was the what was
the
final
uh
decision to that it's not final yet and
the certainly the court cannot force
the legislature to
appropriate money
and as far as a statement made along the
i think anyone that's
spent time in them like we do know that
there's an awful lot of ambiguity
throughout our statutes
so
that stuff needs to get cleaned up so
i think this was not a bad bill
but perhaps it's uh not entirely right
now representative rice i'm sorry
thank you thank you mr chairman so i
think you know i i do think that that
this bill is just too much but i do want
to say that i think it came from a place
of where the representative that
sponsored it has seen and heard a lot
from the people
um regarding the court system uh
primarily the family court system
um and and i believe that it came from a
good place but i i think we have to find
thank you
representative silver
thank you mr chairman
um
i agree that this came from good
intentions
uh we know
that the the road to wherever is paid
for good intentions
um
my problem is that
there's no bifurcation in the language
of this proposal between interpretations
of state statutes and interpretations of
the state constitution
interpretations of the state statute of
a state statute if we don't agree with
it we had a we had some bill i believe
we discussed earlier today
we pass a different bill we passed a
bill changing the statute we have the
ability already without this
constitutional amendment to overturn a
court decision interpreting a statute
we get the problem gets into
trying to overturn a decision by the
state supreme court interpreting the
constitution
that's a much more difficult issue it's
been an issue that of course in the
federal courts was decided very very
long ago
and who is the final interpreter or the
arbiter of what the u.s constitution
means
and the u.s supreme court said oh it's
us
and that's the old marbury versus
madison case and that's been the law now
for
you know a couple centuries
so
uh right or wrong that's the system that
we operate under
the system also that we operate under in
the state just like the federal system
is one of a separation of powers
we make the laws executive enforces the
laws and the judiciary
interprets the laws that's what it's
supposed to be
this would put us into a position
of being a super judiciary on
interpretations of a state constitution
so i don't believe that that
if we if we have a dis agreement with
the state supreme court's interpretation
of our state constitution
we need to overcome that
by passing a constitutional amendment i
have let the people pass a
constitutional amendment
that's the way to do it but we should we
could should not have the ability by a
simple majority vote of the general
court to overturn a state supreme court
decision interpreting the state
constitution that's to me is a violation
of the concept of separation of powers
i'm not a big you know we've talked
about starry decisis there's a lot of a
lot of talk about the the effect of
stereo decisis
in our judicial system and there's a lot
of criticism about story decisis
it's
not something that i'm a big fan of
there are some supreme court justices
that have written
very critically of it if starry decisis
was such an important
inviolate principle
we would still have the dred scott
decision and we would have the separate
but equal before the brown versus board
of education decisions in the federal
system so starry decisis can be overcome
and it's not inviolate so i don't i
don't you know have a lot of concerns
about that but i would have a lot of
concerns if we try to put ourselves in
the general court in a position of
overturning supreme court decisions
interpreting the state constitution
thank you
i'll be brief i just wanted to enjoy
saying that
i
agree with representative silver 100
percent
i don't know how often i'm going to say
that as the weeks and months go on but
certainly i can say that today
um
to a certain extent it's it's whose ox
is being gored uh we have a uh a
constitutional provision section uh
article uh 2a i think
uh that speaks about uh the right of
citizens to bear arms in new hampshire
the state constitution
so let's say a
a a legislative session took place
and the legislature passed a law
that said nobody can own any guns in new
hampshire under state law
um is that going to just automatically
supersede by majority vote what the
state constitution says
i should think not
and that's kind of the fundamental
problem
with uh
with this
proposed constitutional amendment we
have a way of amending the constitution
and this would substitute a different
way of amending the constitution
are there any other
uh
yes representative
[Music]
thank you mr chairman so i want a second
there's a couple things here that i
think are very worthy of consideration
so the idea of majority vote i don't
particularly agree that that the
general court should be able to overturn
any court decision by majority vote
but i do think
that the general court
should be the final
decision maker
as already talked about we're the
closest ones to the people
we do make the laws
and
it was a time in our history when
the court system was not held in the
i think that the general court should be
maybe by two-thirds vote of both houses
maybe by 60 percent something like that
should be able to to overturn a supreme
court decision and just say look we're a
branch for government
we have as much authority
to interpret the constitution
as the court does
and we're doing that
and the court
should say in its own
well
there are times when the court oversteps
and we should be able to stop their
overstepping
by simply overruling them as opposed to
just ignoring them which is what we do
now
okay
any other comments
questions you're ready to go
are there motion that we uh
sorry about that are you ready to um
entertain a motion
yes
um i would then um like to move itl
on
cacr10
mr chair there was already a motion on
the floor by representing
representative smith we already have a
motion pending i'm sorry i thought she
all right and so we do have a motion the
motion is to make ca the proposed ca
cacr10
inexpedient to legislate
and i'll call upon the
clerk to call the role
inexpedient to legislate on caacr 10
representative
mclean
yes
representative sylvia
whoops i'm in the wrong field there we
go
uh representative alexander yes
i'm gonna get back over there i wish you
something's wrong here hang on a second
oh i see what i did
so this is me i want to go over here
put one
up here
and put one two
two
okay
now i'm there
now
representative alexander your vote was
yes
i'm gonna get to that where am i
i could do something about my cursor
here that's the only problem i got okay
three
representative rice
yes representative silber yes
yes
representative kelly
representative tosh
yes
representative trottier
representative smith
yes representative burns
yes
representative oregon
uh yes
cs
yes
representative kenny
representative mcbees
yes
mr chairman
does that one have any objection to it
going on on the consent calendar
no mr chairman
and
that being the case without objection
our recommendation on cacr 10 which is
expedient to legislate will go on the
consent calendar
and
uh
is that representative dilorenzo are you
yes
thank you
okay
it's been a busy day a long day thank
you all
everybody for being so cooperative and
patient with all that's going on
and will
unless you have any other business
oop i see representative sylvia has his
hand up
just wanted to check and make sure all
the members got the amendment to hb 331
the asset forfeiture bill
yes
it would would have been in your
legislative email
today
did you send it today
i think i sent it yesterday
i think i do
if anybody doesn't uh holler and i'll
thank you
and representative rice
representative soviet could you send me
that
please
anything else
thank you so much everybody we'll see
you next week